Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 27. Und heute reden wir mal über Kriegsroboter.
Also sagen wir mal so, eigentlich Drohnen, aber der Name Drohne oder der Begriff Drohne, der ist so schwammig und undefinierbar geradezu, dass wir das ein bisschen allgemeiner fassen und Kriegsroboter sagen.
genau, also wo der Name Drohne herkommt, da können wir auch später noch drauf, das ist ein bisschen lustig.
Wobei richtig klar ist, es gibt nur diese Theorie, die sehr schön...
genau, die ist zu schön, dass wir sie nicht erwähnen. Wir werden sie später noch erwähnen. Gut, also wir fangen mal ein bisschen mit der Geschichte an. Die ersten Dinge, die man vielleicht als Drohnen bezeichnen könnte, waren so, was in der Geschichte recorded war, aus 1849 gab es der erste Einsatz von Drohnen oder sowas, was man so nennen könnte, war möglicherweise, als die Österreicher Venedig angegriffen haben, da kamen sie nämlich nicht so richtig ran, nur hängen den ganzen Lagunen davor und ihre Artlerie reichte nicht so weit und dann haben sie in den Ballons gebaut, die Sprengstoff-Payloads hatten, um die dann da halt auszulösen über der Stadt. Also hat die Fehlerquote auch relativ hoch, aber...
Sie sind teilweise auch zurückgeweht.
Ja, teilweise auch zurückgeweht, aber es ist also relativ typisch in der Geschichte von Drohnen, dass es immer wieder gerne mal schiefgeht und dann auch gerne mal auch katastrophal schiefgeht. Und das war halt auch damals schon so. Also dieses Konzept mit den Ballons, die irgendwelche Dinge irgendwo hintragen und abwerfen, taucht in der Geschichte dann immer mal wieder auf. Dass also man versucht sozusagen, okay, man kann die Windrichtungen hinreichend gut vorhersagen, dass man dem Ballon mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was da dran hängt, Brandbomben oder Bomben vertraut, dass er über dem richtigen Ziel dann nur herunterkommt.
Es hilft natürlich, wenn das Ziel groß genug ist. Die Japaner haben im Zweiten Weltkrieg eine relativ, also hier relativ wohlbekannte, in Amerika sehr unbekannte Sache gemacht. Die haben nämlich auch so Ballons mit Brandsetzen sehr hoch in die Luft getan, weil da die Windströmung relativ gut vorhersagbar ist und die sind dann an allen möglichen Orten über Amerika runtergekommen. Und die haben halt keine andere gute Strategie gehabt, Amerika anzugreifen.
Das war halt vor dem Zeitalter von Fernlenkwaffen.
Und bevor es U-Boote gab mit irgendwelchen raketenlauschdingern. Und die Antwort der Amis war ganz spannend. Sie haben nämlich verboten, dass die Presse darüber berichtet. Damit die Japaner nicht wissen, ob es funktioniert hat oder nicht.
Dass er tatsächlich eine interessante Methode dem Feind die Informationen darüber, ob seine Methoden erfolgreich sind, zu verweigern, führt natürlich schon dazu, dass er möglicherweise dann das Programm abbricht, weil er nicht weiß, ob es erfolgreich ist und wie seine Investition wert ist.
Also Wikipedia hat ein schönes Bild von einer von diesen Bomben-Dingern. Das ist ganz witzig. Ja, das gibt es heute. Also jetzt nicht dasselbe, aber eine ähnliche Sache, dass du einfach Brandsätze absetzt und dann hoffst, wenn die vielleicht nicht die Menschen treffen, dass die Menschen dann die Brandsätze treffen, sind ja diese Splitterbomben mit den kleinen Bombenplätzen, die dann irgendwie attraktiv für Kinder aussehen und dann großen Schaden anrichten.
Aber gut, es sind andere Kategorien Waffen. Also die ersten Dinge, die man so als Drohnen im heutigen Sinne bezeichnen könnte, waren eigentlich große Modellflugzeuge, die benutzt wurden, um Luftabwehrkanoniere zu trainieren. Also dazu dienten, dass irgendjemand flog halt dieses Ding da lang und dann sollte der Flaggkanonier versuchen, dieses Ziel zu treffen.
Bevor es Computersimulationen gab, musste man das ja auch irgendwie trainieren.
Ja, und die wurden in riesigen Stückzahlen gebaut, mehrere zehntausend Stück. Also eines dieser, der bekanntere, war so ein Caddaring Bug. Ja, so ein großes Modellflugzeug, einfach mit einem kleinen Verbrennungsmotor, was per Funk gesteuert wurde.
Wobei das ja immer noch die Idee ist, dass die möglichst billig sind und dass du tausende davon produzieren kannst. Also eigentlich in der naiven Vorstellung, in der Praxis ist das nicht ganz so. Kommen wir auch dazu.
Ja gut, aber auf jeden Fall ist so ein Modellflugzeug, was irgendwie so aus Pappe und Holz besteht, deutlich billiger als ein richtiges Flugzeug, insbesondere noch weil es viel kleiner ist.
Die Zielvorstellung ist es immer noch nicht, dass die Drohnen irgendwann so billig werden, dass man wirklich was spart gegenüber den normalen bemannten Fliegern.
Ja, das werden wir später noch ein bisschen erläutern. Da gibt es noch so ein interessantes Trivia-Bit und zwar Meriden Monroe, die wurde entdeckt bei der Arbeit in einer dieser Fabriken, die diese Modellflugzeuge herstellte, im Krieg für die Trainierung von Luftabwehr kanonierend. Und musste dann irgendwie kurz darauf später da nicht mehr arbeiten, sondern fing dann halt ihren Beruf als fotografiert werdende an. Im Krieg gab es eine Menge an Entwicklungen, also auch im ersten Weltkrieg zum Beispiel gab es schon die ersten Versuche, Flugzeuge so umzubauen, dass sie per Funk kontrolliert werden konnten. Also dass man sie aus der Ferne oder aus einem anderen Flugzeug heraus steuern konnte. Und dann gab es dieses sogenannte Konzept des Lufttorpedos, also dass man halt ein Flugzeug mit Sprengstoff vollgeladen hat und es dann ferngelenkt aus einem anderen Flugzeug heraus zum Beispiel ausgeklinkt hat, aus einem größeren, um es dann halt zum Ziel zu fliegen. Und da gab es eine große Vielfalt von Sachen, also auch die Deutschen haben da ziemlich intensiv dran geforscht und ziemlich intensiv daran gebaut. So richtig zur Einsatzreife gelangt das dann eigentlich erst so in den 50ern, als die Amerikaner da in großem Maße solche Systeme gebaut haben. Aber da wandelte sich eigentlich der Fokus relativ zügig hin zur Aufklärung. Also halt Fotos machen und funkaufklärung betreiben und zu versuchen halt möglichst wenig Personal dabei zu verheizen. Also wir erinnern uns dunkel halt im Kalten Krieg, bevor es Satelliten gab und auch noch eine Weile nachdem es Satelliten gab, wegen der Auflösung, sind die ja da mit bewaren Flugzeugen, zum Beispiel über die Wetternürn geflogen oder über China und haben dabei dann doch irgendwie relativ viele Besatzungen verloren, weil naja, die hatten dann alle meistens merkwürdige Unfälle. Und dann gab es da so Geschichten, dass die Soviets dann angefangen haben, Navigationsradio-Barken zu verschieben, um die dann in ihren eigenen luftraum zu locken und da abschießen zu können, ohne dass sie sozusagen dafür verurteilt werden konnten, weil die waren ja offensichtlich im eigenen luftraum. Dann haben die Amerikaner halt parallel zu all möglichen anderen Entwicklungen halt auch angefangen, Drohnen im größeren Maßstab zu bauen. Die krasseste, die sie gebaut und eingesetzt haben, war die Locket D21 oder M21. Und zwar haben sie da einen Hyperschall-Drohnenkörper gebaut und haben den auf das schnellste und dickste Flugzeug, was sie hatten, nämlich die Blackbird, draufgeschnallt. Also was an sich schon halt irgendwie ein, wir hatten das glaube ich schon mal erwähnt.
Das Ding war doch an sich schon der Hammer, dieses Blackbird-Teil.
Also das war halt so, was zur Technologie angeht, völlig futuristisch. Also zum größten Ausdruck ist Titanen gebaut und ist halt irgendwie machtrei geflogen und die Drohne eben auch. Und deswegen haben sie die halt kombiniert, also dass sie halt die Drohne und dieses Monster-Flugzeug zusammen kombiniert haben, um dann China überfliegen zu können. Und die haben sie dann tatsächlich auch eingesetzt. Interessanterweise eben auch nicht militärisch, sondern auch unter der Kontrolle der CIA. Das war halt schon damals so, dass die solche Flüge eben nicht unter der Kontrolle des Militärs, sondern unter der Kontrolle des Geheimdienstes passiert sind, um im Zweifel halt einfach auch irgendwie sich nicht rechtfertigen zu müssen und also nicht so viele Fragen beantworten zu müssen.
Wobei das Militär auch eigentlich seinen eigenen Geheimdienst hat für sowas, aber das ist immer so eine lustige... Ist auch eine Frage, wo das Geld herkommt, aus welchem Topf. Ja, und deswegen wird das ganz gerne hin und her geschoben. Aber ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen darauf eingehen, was für eine Hammertechnologie das ist, wenn du mehr als, wenn du Hyperschall fliegst. Also die haben zwar den Körper des Flugzeuges aus Titan gemacht, aber wenn man so schnell fliegt, dann gibt es eine unglaubliche Reibungshitze und das Material dehnt sich aus. Und um das machen zu können, haben die das so gemacht, dass der Tank leckte, außer du flogst Hyperschall. Also bis du Hyperschall erreicht hast mit dieser Blackbird, sobte da das Benzin raus und das ist ja ein, also ich sage jetzt Benzin, aber das ist ein hochkarzinogenes Zeug, was sie da getankt haben. Und wenn das Flugzeug dann seine richtige Geschwindigkeit erreicht hat, dann hat sich eben das Material so ausgedehnt, dass es nicht mehr leckte. Also diese Art von und und, das war, obwohl das Titan war, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie...
Sie haben es halt eben absichtlich so gebaut, weil sonst hätte ihn halt die Spannung Risse verursacht. Das ist lustig, weil für ein Blackbird gibt es das Handbuch. Das ist tatsächlich irgendwann publiziert worden. Und da kann man so lustige Dinge drin sehen, wie zum Beispiel, dass die Standardprozedur dafür sitzt, ohne die Drohne, weil die Drohne war nicht so erfolgreich.
Also wenn eine Rakete kommt, Standardprozedur ist beschleunigen.
genau, erstmal beschleunigen. Oder aber zum Beispiel, die Standardprozedur zum Losfliegen war, die haben ein bisschen getankt, sind gestartet. Dass das Ding heiß wurde, also haben sie sozusagen einmal auf den Nachbrenner gedrückt, dass das Ding heiß wurde, sind wieder gelandet und haben dann getankt. Oder nachdem sich das dann halt irgendwie als so offen herausstellt, haben sie dann halt nur mit dem getankt, was sie brauchten, um es einmal dicht zu kriegen. Also halt einmal aufs Gas drücken quasi, uns einmal heiß werden lassen und haben es dann halt luftbetankt. Diese D21-Drohne war jetzt nicht so ein großer Erfolg, also die ist ihnen halt häufiger mal runtergefallen, eine ist in China auch runtergefallen und dann an einem Luftfahrtmuseum gelandet und so. Aber dieses Trägerflugzeug ist halt irgendwie so ein Beispiel dafür, was die Amerikaner halt im Kalten Krieg getrieben haben, wo man sich wirklich fragt, was wäre gewesen, wenn es so weitergegangen wäre. Also wenn die halt einfach mit dieser Art von Entwicklung und diesen Mengen an Geld, die sie darauf geworfen haben, so weitergemacht hätten.
Das kann man inzwischen auch in Museen sehen, dieses Flugzeug.
Stimmt, in Museum of Flight zum Beispiel steht so ein Ding in Seattle.
genau.
Und da kann man sich auch ins Cockpit setzen.
Ja, das ist echt der Hammer.
Da hab ich ja ein Foto gemacht und hab dann eine Weile gesucht nach, da gibt es nämlich einen Schalter im Cockpit, der ist mit Thunderstorm gelabelt.
Und steht im Handbuch, was das macht?
genau, im Handbuch steht, was das macht, ist tatsächlich ein reaktiver Cockpit-Beleuchtungsmodus. Beleuchtung Cockpits passt sich automatisch den Umgehungshalligkeiten an. Und wenn ein Blitz kommt, würde sie ja denken, ist es gerade super hell und ausgehen. Und dann hast du für einen Moment halt, weil du sowieso gebildet bist von dem Blitz, siehst du nichts. Und deswegen haben sie halt einen Modus eingebaut, den Thunderstorm-Modus.
Dass der dann auch ganz hell wird?
Dass der dann auch ganz hell wird. Also dass er halt, so zu sagen, deine Sicht erhalten bleibt.
Probleme, die du und ich nie haben werden.
genau, ich dachte vielleicht zuerst so, cool, sie haben dann einen Gewitter eingebaut. Und dieses Flugzeug, also vor allem, jemand steht vor diesem Flugzeug und denkt so, hm, also eigentlich glaube ich es ja nicht, aber vielleicht haben sie auch einen Blitzgenerator eingebaut.
Man weiß es ja nicht.
Nee, man kann es nicht wissen, so an der Stelle. Na gut, okay.
Aber was man noch sagen muss bei diesen ganzen Flugzeugen, die kosten in der Anschaffung eine Menge Geld, das ist klar, aber die kosten auch im Betrieb eine Menge Geld. Also das wird in irgendwie Geld pro Flugstunde gerechnet und Größenordnung sind da irgendwie so eine Million pro Flugstunde. Und also ist es unfassbar, weil da ist auch Wartung und so mit drin, Instandsetzung, Ersatzteile, ja, wenn irgendwas, oder wenn Upgrades eingefahren werden, weil die werden ja auch nicht nur gewartet, sondern da wird ja nachgerüstet, wenn es irgendwie neue Waffen und so gibt. Und das wird halt pro Flugstunde umgeschlagen und da kommen unfassbare Kosten zustande. Und deswegen ist es so, dass die Drohnen sich lohnen, selbst wenn sie auch astronomisch viel kosten.
Die Rechnung können wir gleich später noch mal aufmachen. Lass mal noch ein bisschen weitergehen in der Geschichte. Interessant ist nämlich ein relativ wenig bekannter Fakt, dass im Vietnamkrieg wurden richtig viele Drohnen eingesetzt. Also gerade Aufklärungsdrohnen, die waren halt relativ simpel. Also die sind halt einfach nach einer Initialnavigation Strecke geflogen. Das heißt, sie haben Wegpunkte abgeflogen an bestimmten Stellen, die Kamera aufgemacht, an bestimmten Stellen die Kamera zugemacht, um dann halt zu einem Landegebiet zu fliegen und da am falschen runter zu kommen. Und da gab es richtig so mehrere tausend Drohnenmissionen, die die Amerikaner während des Vietnamkriegs geflogen haben, mit allen möglichen Arten von Drohnen. Also sie haben auch richtig viele verloren. Ja, also ich glaube sie haben irgendwie von 3.400 haben sie 500 verloren oder irgendwie sowas in der größten Klasse. Also es war halt schon relativ viel. Interessant ist da halt auch die Überschneidung zu Großmissiles. Also wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, so eine Drohne, also halt was, was halt irgendwo hinfliegt und einen Wegpunkt folgt oder irgendwie Terrain folgt, unterscheidet sich ja eigentlich nicht besonders groß von einer Großmissile, die halt auch irgendwo hinfliegt und irgendwie dem Terrain folgt, nur dass sie halt am Ende nicht zurückkommt, um ihre Filme abzuliefern, sondern umzumachen. Und dementsprechend sind diese Technologien, die da verwendet wurden, auch sehr eng verwandt. Und diese Abstammung von Drohnen, dass sie halt ursprünglich eben mal als Zielsimulationsgeräte gebaut wurden, also primär verwendet wurden.
Zu einmal Benutzung?
Na ja, entweder einmal Benutzung oder halt mit einem Offset. Also es gibt halt auch diese Methode, dass du halt, wenn du halt so ein Flagg kanoniert trainierst, dann stellst du halt ein Offset an der Visiereinrichtung ein, sodass du immer dahinter schießt.
Ja wieso, das ist doch aber der Fehler, den du gerade wegtrainieren willst, dass die Leute ein bisschen vor die...
Na ja, die zielen halt ja schon vor, aber sozusagen dadurch, dass du den Offset einstellst, verlierst du halt weniger Drohnen. Trotzdem willst du halt natürlich da keinem manken...
Aber dann siehst du ja nicht, ob er getroffen hätte, oder?
Ja doch, weil die schleppst du entweder mit der Drohne, schleppst du halt was hinterher.
Achso, da hängt dann so ein Teil hinten dran?
Da hängt dann so eine Zielscherbe hinten dran. Aber trotzdem ist das für bemannte Piloten nicht sehr beliebt. Das ist ein toller Job. Deswegen hat man da halt diese Zielgeräte. Interessant daran ist, dass Drohnen lange Zeit in Nomenklaturen von Armeen nicht als Drohnen geführt wurden, sondern eben als Zielsimulationsgeräte, auch wenn sie ganz andere Aufgaben dienten.
Hat das irgendeinen Hintergrund, dass sie kein Geld ausgeben durften für Drohnen?
Sie wollten halt in der Regel nicht sagen, was sie schon können.
Aber die Budgets sind doch eh alle geheim, oder nicht?
Ja, aber trotzdem so ein bisschen, weiß man ja, was weiß ich dann. Da ist halt irgendwie keine Ahnung. Also ein bisschen dazu, dass in einigen Ländern halt aktiv, was weiß ich, wenn die sonst Ärger mit den Nachbarn bekommen hätten oder so. Da haben sie halt da ja, wie haben wir noch so 500 Zielsimulationsgeräte rumstehen? Okay, unsere Luftwaffe sind halt nur 25 Flugzeug. Zielsimulationsgeräte haben wir ganz viele.
Gut macht ja Sinn, wenn du sagst, es ist eine Zielsimulation. Also ich finde es immer spannend, wie die Probleme doch übergreifend sind. Also das andere Extrem von einer Drohne wäre ja ein Satellit. Der kommt auch nicht zurück, aber du willst an die Filme irgendwie rankommen, die er macht. Und die Technologien sind natürlich austauschbar. Also man könnte sich auch eine Drohne vorstellen, die das nicht filmt, sondern zurückfunkt und kein Aufnahme-Equipment da hat, was auch den Vorteil hätte, dass so wenn die abgeschossen wird, nicht sehen kannst, was sie gefilmt hat.
Das passiert tatsächlich auch, man muss natürlich überlegen, ob das, was nach oben funkt, also ob die Drohne die ganze Zeit senden soll, weil das kannst du natürlich auch anpeilen und sehen. Und das ist halt so eine schwierige Abwägung, die auch relativ viel von dieser Drohnenentwicklung bestimmt ist, lässt du die Drohne senden, kommunizierst du aktiv oder vertraust du darauf, dass die Drohne halt schon ihren Job tut, ohne dass du groß mit ihr reden musst? Fliegst du sie live oder fliegst du sie nicht live? Das sind so die, also wie viel Autonomie baut man dieses System ein, das ist halt eine große spannende Frage.
Das hängt ja auch von den Gegenmaßnahmen ab, mit denen man kämpfen muss, nicht?
Warte mal, mir fällt gerade noch eine Geschichte ein, die wir noch einbringen sollten, bevor wir die Sache mit dem Kalten Krieg verlassen. Und zwar die krasseste Drohne, die die Amis jemals geplant haben, war nämlich eine nuklearbetriebene Drohne.
Wobei Drohne ist auch zu, finde ich jetzt, den falschen Begriff. Weil die geplant haben, das Teil, naja, an sich war das...
Automatischer Bomber.
genau, aber Kamikaze-Bomber, unbemannt. Ja, aber die Idee war, dass der abstürzt und explodiert.
Aber erst am Ende. Also der eigentliche Einsatzplan war, dass das Ding 26 Atombomben trägt und die Wegpunkte abfliegt, dabei die Atombomben abwirft und nebenbei noch die Landstriche verseucht, eben dadurch, dass das Ding halt einen offenen Atomreaktor...
Wir sollten erklären, wie das funktioniert. Also das Spannende an dem Teil war, das war ein Jet.
Also ein Nuklear-Ramjet-Antrieb ist es.
Das war ein Jet-Antrieb, da wird halt die Luft erhitzt, stark, aber eben nicht durch Zuführung von Benzin, was man dann anzündet, sondern durch Vorbeiführen an einem offenen Atomreaktor, was eben den Nachteil hat oder den Vorteil an der Stelle, dass die Luft massiv radioaktiv verseucht wird. Was aber den Planern damals wurscht war, weil das Ding sollte ja über dem Feindesland kreisen und die können ruhig verseucht werden.
Naja, es gab zwei Möglichkeiten.
Aber das ist halt nie wirklich eingesetzt worden.
Nee, sie haben es nie gebaut.
Weil das Problem war auch, dass du das nicht lauschen konntest, ohne dich selbst zu verseuchen.
Du konntest nicht lauschen und dich selbst zu verseuchen und es gab halt noch so Probleme. Das Ding gab halt zwei Varianten. Die eine war Unterschall, die andere Überschall. Und das Überschall-Ding wäre halt so groß geworden und hätte eine so dramatische Überschallknall-Schockwelle erzeugt, dass schon allein die zerstörerisch gewesen wäre. So, also da haben sie erst die Simulationen rausgefunden. Und dann war halt das Problem, dass der taktisch sinnvollste Einsatz, der strategisch sinnvollste Einsatzweg wäre gewesen, dieses Ding halt einfach überm Ozean außerhalb des sowjetischen luftraums kreuzen zu lassen, bis man es dann einsetzen würde. Also ähnlich wie diese Teapot-Missions, wo sie halt mit die 52 mal bis vor die Grenze geflogen sind und dann wieder umgedreht haben. Und dabei hätte man natürlich die Atmosphäre brutal verseucht. Aber am Ende war halt der Plan, wenn das Ding halt eingesetzt werden sollte, war, dass es halt mit seinem Nuklearantrieb halt in die Sowjetunion fliegt, da halt seine Zielpunkte abfliegt, da halt die Bomben ausklinkt und dann irgendwie sich auf sein finales Primärziel stürzt, um da halt einfach irgendwie mit seinem Reaktor halt eine große, keine Ahnung, ob sie den Reaktor vielleicht noch irgendwie in den hyperkritischen Bereich gefahren hätten, um noch eine Explosion zu erzeugen. Aber jedenfalls, gut, da wäre vermutlich nicht so viel übrig geblieben am Ende, aber...
Das Spannende ist natürlich, wenn du so einen Atomreaktor hast, dass der mehr ausdauer hat als ein reguläres Flugzeug.
genau.
Und das Teil hätte irgendwie wieviel 30 Tage oder so rumkreisen können. Das ist schon bemerkenswert.
Also das war halt so der Punkt, wo die Amerikaner halt mal die Idee dieser Drohnenentwicklung so auf die Spitze getrieben haben, weil...
Wir denken das jetzt mal durch, was am Ende passieren kann.
genau, was am Ende passieren kann. Naja, was dann halt interessanterweise dabei rauskam, war aber unter anderem Technologie, die in den Cruise Missiles gelandet ist, weil was in einem dieser Teilprojekte gelaufen ist, war das eine Tertium, also die Terrainfolgerada.
Erklär doch mal den Unterschied zwischen normaler Rakete, ICBM und Cruise Missiles.
genau. Also eine normale Rakete hat halt einen Treibsatz und die hat hinten so kleine Steuerfinnen oder auch vorne. Die schießt du ab, die hat dann so, keine Ahnung, so maximal ein, zwei Minuten Brennzeit. Also jetzt gerade bei Kurzstreckenraketen, bei Mittelstreckenraketen halt ein bisschen länger und bei ICBMs glaube ich sechs Minuten Brennzeit oder so. Und danach fliegt diese Rakete ballistisch. Das heißt, sie folgt dann halt einer Parabelkurve und macht dann auch am Ende einen Flug halt nochmal eine Korrektur, um ins Ziel zu kommen. Da unterscheiden sich Kurzstreckenraketen nicht sehr von Interkonzentralraketen, außer dass Interkonzentralraketen aufgrund der größeren Geschwindigkeiten in Orbit erreichen. Das heißt also, die treten in den normalen Erdorbit ein außerhalb der Atmosphäre oder in der oberen Schichtatmosphäre und machen dann halt entweder einen Teilorbit oder sogar mehrere Orbits, bevor sie wieder einen Tritt in die Atmosphäre machen. Und dadurch, dass sie so brutal schnell sind, gibt es halt nur relativ wenig Abweichmöglichkeiten. Ne Cruzmüssel hingegen ist eigentlich ein relativ langsam fliegendes Ding. Also es wird eigentlich gebaut eher wie ein Flugzeug. Es hat kleine Stummeflüge, hat ein relativ großes Triebwerk und fliegt dann halt so mit irgendwie so was wie 600 bis 900 kmh, also meistens Unterschallgeschwindigkeit, und fliegt lange, also halt teilweise bis zu zwei Stunden oder drei Stunden, und sehr tief. Das heißt, sie fliegt halt dem Terrain folgend flach über den Boden. Deswegen also dieser TACOM Radar, der halt dazu dient, aus Geländestrukturen, die per Radar erfasst werden, zu erkennen, wo dieses Ding eigentlich ist. Und schleicht sich dann halt so durch die Täler und irgendwie über die Hügel und versucht halt möglichst unterhalb der Erfassungshöhe von normalem Luftfahrtradar zu bleiben. Und diese Großmissiles sind halt entwickelt worden, eben weil die Abwehrsysteme gegen normale Raketen relativ gut geworden waren und weil es halt Verträge gab. Also halt die Verträge gegen Intercontinental-Raketen und gegen gegen Mittelstrecken-Raketen haben ja dann relativ explizit verboten, welche Art von Flugkörpern reguliert werden. Also wie viel man davon besitzen darf, wie viele Sprengköpfe da drauf sind und so. Und diese Großmissiles sind demgegenüber so was, naja, die sind halt so ein bisschen wie so eine Chessner halt. Also es ist halt nicht viel größer. Da passt halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so was wie 3 bis 400 Kilo, an manchen auch eine Tonne, aber nicht viel mehr Warhead rein. Der kann halt konventionell sein, der kann halt nuklear sein. Und das macht halt eben für die Militäristen einen interessanten Aspekt dabei aus, so eine Intercontinental-Rakete kann man nicht einsetzen eigentlich. Also selbst wenn man eine Intercontinental-Rakete mit einem konventionellen Sprengkopf ausrüstet, kann man die nicht einsetzen, weil jeder sofort denkt, wenn er so ein Ding auf dem Radar sieht, jetzt geht's los. Na, das ist halt so, geht halt nicht. So eine Kruzmissal...
Wunderschnell zurückschlägt.
genau, bei einer Kruzmissal ist es aber so, dass die, also die bisher eingesetzt wurden und davon wurden ja halt viele hundert eingesetzt in den letzten Kriegen. Die waren natürlich alle konventionell bestückt. Also deswegen ist bei einer Kruzmissal halt erstmal die Erwartungshaltung, dass du halt irgendwie im Zweifel konventionell angegriffen wirst oder vielleicht irgendjemand anders konventionell angegriffen wird, wenn es an dir vorbe fliegt.
Wir sollten zur einen Ordnung sagen, eine Boeing mit Passagieren drin fliegt schneller als so eine Kruzmissal. Nicht viel, aber so ein bisschen. Also das ist die Größenordnung, von der wir hier reden. Es ist nicht irgendwie wie so ein Düsenjäger.
Der fliegt halt so Reisegeschwindigkeit. Also es gibt halt schon auch Überschall Kruzmissals, aber die sind halt relativ teuer. Und da Kruzmissals ja eben eine Missal ist, das heißt, sie fliegt halt nur einmal, versucht man da natürlich den Preis halt auch irgendwie einigermaßen im Rahmen zu halten. Und dementsprechend sind die halt in der Regel nicht für Überschall ausgelegt. Also es gibt halt welche für irgendwie Einsatzzwecke, wie zum Beispiel initiales Ausschalten der Luftabwehr. Dafür wurden die halt auch durchaus konstruiert, die halt zum Beispiel dann noch eine Überschall-Endphase haben. Also die machen dann halt kurz vorher nochmal den Nachbrenner an, um halt den kritischen Bereich, wo sie halt durch das Radar durch müssen, den möglichst schnell zurückzulegen. Aber das sind halt eher so Sonderfälle.
Ich möchte noch mal zurückkommen zu diesem am Terrain erkennen, wo man ist. Denn mir ist das zum ersten Mal begegnet, als in dem Kontext, ja, GPS kann man ja manipulieren oder jammen oder man kann da ein Offset einbauen. Und das ist die Gegentechnologie. Aber eigentlich ist es historisch die ältere Technologie.
Diese Terrainfolgen ist sozusagen der zweite Schritt nach der sogenannten Inertialnavigation. Also alle militärischen Drohnen der neueren Zeit haben eine sogenannte Inertialnavigation drin. Die besteht aus einem Kreisekompass und einer Geschwindigkeitsmeißung.
Das stellt man sich vor wie beim Handy, oder? Handy haben sowas ja auch heute, die merken halt, wenn du es drehst.
Also ein Handy ist heutzutage halt sensorisch drin, mit dem man problemlos halt eine Kursmisse erbauen könnte.
Es gibt ja noch dieses lustige Detail bei GPS.
Warte, lass mich kurz das mal in der Inertialnavigation zu erklären. Also in der Inertialnavigation funktioniert es halt so, dass man halt Richtung Geschwindigkeit und Beschleunigung misst und daraus halt seinen Kurs extra poliert. Also man weiß, wie lange man in welche Richtung geflogen ist und wo man losgeflogen ist, dann kann man quasi wie halt alte Segelschiff-Navigation sich zum Ziel navigieren. Und je mehr Sensoren man dafür hat, desto präziser ist es. Also je besser man zum Beispiel seine Beschleunigung hat und seine Geschwindigkeit über Grund messen kann, indem man zum Beispiel halt auch weiß, wie viel Wind grad von vorne kommt oder indem man die Geschwindigkeit misst mit einem Sensor, der Richtung Boden zeigt, zum Beispiel in einem Radar, desto besser kann man halt rausfinden, wo man ist. Und die Großmissl-Technologie, die aus den 80ern die Originale, in der halt so 16-Bit-Prozessortechnologie war, das die da drin steckte, da haben sie einen Radar gebaut, dieses Telekom-Radar, was es dann in dutzend Interaktionen gab, was Geländeformationen erkannt hat und gematcht hat und danach diese Inertialnavigation nachkorrigiert hat.
Wie habe ich mir das vorzustellen? Haben die dann so ein Navisystem, Kartenmaterial mit höhen Dings an Bord gehabt? Nur für die Regionen, wo sie eingesetzt werden?
Die wurden reingeladen, wenn die Mission reinprogrammiert wurde. Und zwar quasi einen Korridor, den hast du aber dann so ausgewählt, dass du schönes Terrain hattest. Du wählst sie ohnehin aus, wenn du gerade ersetzten, du willst diese Wetterdornen angreifen. Dann wählst du halt den Flugfahrt deiner Kurs, das muss halt so aus, dass sie halt a. nicht irgendwie alle denselben fliegen, b. dass sie halt die bekannten Radarinstallationen vermeiden und da fliegen oder zumindest möglichst schnell durch sind, c. dass du halt dir Geländeformationen auswählst, die halt, die vor allen Dingen dir auch möglichst viel Deckung bieten. Also zum Beispiel tiefe Täler, da scheint der Radar halt nicht rein.
Also ich stelle mir halt vor, nimm mal an, du willst jetzt Kansas angreifen. Dann hast du doch verloren, oder? Das geht doch nur, wenn du irgendwie schönes, schönes Terrain mit, mit irgendwie Kanada...
Die sind halt für Mitteleuropa gebaut worden.
Na und? Afghanistan, ne?
Da wurden sie dann halt eingesetzt, da hatten sie dann schon GPS.
Ja, aber es eignet sich hervorragend für diese Berge, die gingen aber, du hast halt verloren, wenn du...
Na gut, ich meine, sie haben halt, sie wussten halt, sie brauchen noch irgendwas anderes. Deswegen haben sich dann ja auch GPS gebaut. Also noch aus dutzenden anderen Gründen, aber einer der Gründe war halt, dass die Größen müssen halt sauber ankommen. Aber dieses Terrafolgen mit Radar und dieses Matchen von Geländeformationen gegen Radar-Daten, das funktioniert halt nicht überall auf dem Planeten. Also über Meer ist es zum Beispiel auch doof. Aber eben insbesondere, wenn du halt irgendwie Radar unterfliegen willst in so ein bisschen gebürgigen Gelände, ist es halt total super. Weil du da halt einfach in T-Lan fliegen kannst und nicht drüber fliegen musst.
Kann man sowas nicht orten, wenn irgendwie so ein Teil mit Radar... Und die andere Frage, kannst du dem nicht falsches Thema unterschieben, wenn du ihn kommen siehst?
Ja, das ist halt eines der Dinge, die halt unter dem Fachbegriff Electronic Warfare laufen, dass du versuchst halt, die Radar-Return-Impulse zu manipulieren. In der Regel wirst du nicht versuchen, dem einen Tyran zu simulieren, weil es sehr aufwendig wäre. Dafür braucht du jetzt relativ viele Emitter, die du halt irgendwie da im Gelände verstreust und du müsstest wissen, dass es bei dir da lang kommt. Sondern du gemst halt einfach das Radar.
Naja, aber ich meine, um mal den Aufwand zu skizzieren. Die Amis haben ja den Ozeanboden relativ engmaschig mit ihren...
Ja, da ging es aber nicht um einzelne Großmissl, da ging es aber nicht um einzelne Großmissl, die da irgendwo langfliegen, sondern da ging es um irgendwie hunderte von U-Booten.
Ja, dafür geht es um den Meeresboden. Also das ist schon irgendwie eine Größenordnung, die da einfach mal in die Hand genommen wurde.
Aber gut, irgendwie so zwei Dutzend Atom-Ubote mit jeweils zwei Dutzend Interkonzentreer-Raketen zu trecken, ist eine andere Größenordnung, als einen Großmissl am langfliegen zu hindern.
Du musst sie ja nur einmal richtig doll ablenken.
Du musst sie einfach nur finden, wenn du sie gefunden hast. Weil wenn du den Radar siehst, kannst du auch abschießen.
Ja, naja gut, aber es ist natürlich eleganter, wenn sie...
Ja, nee, da jamsst du halt den Radar ein. Also terrain-simulieren ist halt, du weißt halt auch nicht genau, was sie tun. Also das ist halt auch, also wie halt genau dieses Toramatching funktioniert, also welche Features sie da gehen, da müsstest du schon einen in der Hand haben. Ah gut.
Das wäre natürlich ein schöner Hack, wenn ihr einfach so manipuliert, dass sie zurückfliegt und sich selbst bombardieren.
Ja, da müsstest du aber die ganze Strecke covern, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig. Also das glaube ich mit GPS-Buffen dann einfach.
Wie funktioniert denn eigentlich GPS-Buffen?
Na, GPS-Buffen ist eine Technologie, bei der die Amerikaner schon relativ lange Angst hatten. Die GPS-Satelliten funktionieren so, du hast ein Netzwerk von Satelliten, die auf einem mittelhohen Erdorbit um die Erde kreisen. Auf den Satelliten sind Atomuhren und die senden ein Zeitsignal rein. Uhren, Atomuhren, die senden halt ein Zeitsignal. Und die Position dieser Satelliten auf ihrer Bahn ist bekannt. Und der Empfänger bekommt auf einem anderen Kanal, bzw. in einem anderen Bitstrom in dem selben Kanal, die Position und die Bahndaten der Satelliten mitgeteilt. Und kann also sagen, dieses Zeitsignal von diesem Satelliten, was ich jetzt empfange, wurde gesendet, als der Satellit an dieser Position seiner Bahn war. Und wenn man jetzt irgendwie mindestens drei dieser Satellitensignale empfängt, kann man daraus sich ausrechnen, wo man auf der Erdoberfläche ist. Indem man halt die laufzeit des Signals bis zum Empfangspunkt und die Position des Satelliten, ja, es ist halt eine einfache Trilomie-Rechnung.
Warum machen denn die...
Jetzt Jamming? Das ist ja die Frage, wie spuft man ein GPS. Und da gibt es halt mehrere Methoden. Der Weg, den, also jetzt wo es auch zum Beispiel demonstriert, dass man, wie man Drohnen ablenken kann. In den USA gab es ja gerade diesen Versuch, wo sie es im Stadion gemacht haben, dass sie halt einen Helikopter haben in der Luft stehen lassen, einen GPS kontrolliert, dann das GPS gespufft haben und den Helikopter woandershin geflogen haben, also mit diesem kleinen modellhubschrauber. Und was man dazu tut, ist, man nimmt das GPS-Signal, was ohnehin ja vorhanden ist, und verzögert es leicht. Also man baut halt ein Offset ein. Oder man simuliert das Signal komplett, indem man halt einfach die Signale der Satelliten, die ja vorhersagbar sind, komplett simuliert und sie mit einer stärkeren Sendeleistung ausstrahlt. Das GPS-Signal ist wirklich sehr, sehr schwach. Also halt so, deswegen geht GPS halt zum Beispiel auch indoors nicht. Also wenn man im haus ist nicht oder wenn man halt ein feuchtes Blätterdach über sich hat, dann ist es schwierig mit dem GPS. Oder manchmal ist es in der Stadt problematisch, weil Reflektionen da sind oder halt Abschattung, sodass man halt keinen guten Empfang hat. Das heißt also, wenn man auch nur mit einem marginal starken Sender so ein GPS-Signal aussendet, kann man halt das eigentliche GPS-Signal übertönen und der Empfänger wird sich auf dein eigenes Signal locken. Man muss halt mehrere Satelliten simulieren. Das heißt also, man braucht halt ein relativ gutes Digitalradio-Setup dafür. Aber die Technologie dazu haben zumindest Berichten nach die Russen schon im Golfkrieg den Irak angegeben. Also schon vor mittlerweile mehr als zehn Jahren.
Du kannst aber mit nur einem Sender mehr als einen Satelliten simulieren.
Nimmst halt ein Digitalradio dafür, was die Bitströme simuliert auf den entsprechenden Frequenzen.
Okay, und die Gegenmaßnahme ist, dass die für militärische GPS-Signale nochmal so ein Kryptogramm drauf haben.
Es gibt mehrere Gegenmaßnahmen. Die erste ist, dass du Antennen nimmst, die nur straight nach oben empfangen. Also dass du halt keine Signale hast, die nicht wirklich von oben von den Satelliten kommen. Die zweite ist, dass du Face-Deray-Antennen nimmst, also Antennen, die eine relativ schmale Empfangskeule haben und dir mehrere von diesen Empfangskeulen in die Richtung schickst, wo du die Satelliten erwartest. Weil du hast ja einfach die ganze Zeit die Bahndaten vorher wissen. Und du sagst halt, okay, ich will jetzt wirklich nur aus diesem Stück Himmel tatsächlich mein GPS-Signal und aus diesem Stück Himmel, aus diesem Stück Himmel. Das sind halt so Sachen, die man auf der Empfangsseite tun kann. Und das militärische GPS-Signal, da könnte man eigentlich fast noch mal eine Gesendung machen, ist technisch getrennt. Also es gibt halt separate Frequenzen, separate Modulationen und hat eine sehr viel längere Sequenz des Hoppings. Also ein GPS-Signal in der Modulation verteilt die Bits hier auf mehrere Frequenzen. Das heißt, wenn so sehr viel vereinfacht gesagt wird, halt eine Sequenz von Pseudozufallszahlen-Generatoren erzeugt. Und der Empfänger muss diese Sequenz kennen, um zu wissen, zu welcher Zeit, auf welcher Frequenz ein Bit kommt oder in welcher Modulation. Und ist halt für zivile, also für zivile Signale die Sequenz halt relativ kurz. Die weiß halt jeder GPS-Empfängerhersteller. Und fürs meditatorsche Signal ist die halt irgendwie viele tausendfach länger. Dumm ist halt nur, dass sie natürlich in jedem meditatorschen GPS-Empfänger drin ist.
Also Rekeen geht nicht?
Naja, nicht ohne weiteres. Sie haben da so Mechanismen, aber das ist halt, also machen sie nicht so gern, weil dann steht, also du weißt ja, das Problem ist Zuverlässigkeit, weil also Sicherheit, und dann entscheidet man sich immer bei Militär für Zuverlässigkeit. Dementsprechend ist der, ja, dieses Rekeen halt eher eine Future Option so.
Warum nimmt man denn keine geostationären Satelliten? Weil Russland die dann irgendwie abschießen würde über ihrem Terrain oder was?
Nee, weil du dann sehr viel größere Empfänger bräuchtest.
Ach, wie erdnah sind die denn, die GPS-Satelliten?
Müsste ich jetzt mal nachgucken, aber ich glaube, es war so 4000 Kilometer oder so. Wo ist es? Nicht 36.000. Ich gucke gerade noch mal kurz nach, dann können wir das gleich noch klären.
Was mir auch lange Zeit nicht klar war, ist, dass die Satelliten eine relativ kurze lebensdauer haben jeweils. Also nach ein paar Jahren irgendwie musst du dann neun hochschießen. Naja, also ein paar Jahre ist jetzt zu kurz, aber...
Naja, es ist schon durchaus nur in ein paar Jahren. Also die haben insofern Glück, dass die Satelliten relativ lange halten. Also die Orbit-Haltbarkeit der Satelliten ist halt in der Regel länger als geplant. Also die haben relativ gut gebaut, also relativ gute Qualität. Aber die haben halt immer die Notwendigkeit, irgendwie nach und nach Satelliten hinterherzuschießen. So, also es ist halt bei den Russen genauso. Ich glaube, die Russen haben auch ein System, GLONASS. Die Chinesen bauen sich gerade ein System. Und dementsprechend müssen sie halt irgendwie kontinuierlich halt immer dafür sorgen, dass sie mindestens 24 Satelliten da oben haben. Das ist halt so ein Erfordernis, ja.
Ähm, ich sah ja neulich...
Ah, Entschuldigung, 20.000 Kilometer ist der Orbit.
Ja, okay, gut. Ich sah ja neulich, dass die neue Handy-Generation von Samsung GLONASS eingebaut hat.
Ja, warum nicht? Mittlerweile sind es alles sowieso nur...
War das, wir machen jetzt alle, oder war das so ein Einzelding?
Naja, der Unterschied ist halt nicht mehr so groß. Also die Empfänger werden alle sowieso Multinorm, also halt für GPS ohnehin. Und dann will man natürlich vorbereitet sein für Galileo, also für das europäische System. Und GLONASS funktioniert halt auch so ähnlich, also die sind halt technisch, sind die Unterschiede zwischen den Systemen aus der Sicht eines Digitalradios zwar vorhanden, aber jetzt nicht so, dass man es nicht alles in einem Design, sondern in einem Chip-Design bauen könnte. Also macht man es halt in einem Chip-Design.
Was ja auch Absicht ist, ne?
genau, also die sind halt, naja, es hat nicht nur Absicht, sondern halt tatsächlich auch eine Menge mit Physik zu tun. Also mit der Art und Weise, wie halt irgendwie Signale durch die Atmosphäre laufen und welche Properties du in unserem Navigationssignal haben willst. Na gut, wir sind etwas abgeschweift. Eigentlich waren wir bei Drohnen.
Eigentlich waren wir gerade bei Cruise Missiles gewesen.
genau, bei Cruise Missiles. Und diese Cruise Missiles gibt es halt auch in allen möglichen Größen, Farben und Formen. Und einer der Dinge, die halt zum Beispiel auch von deutschen Rüstungskonzern gebaut wird, sind Cruise Missiles, die so genannte Loitering Ammunition sind. Also die hängen halt rum über dem Schlachtfeld.
Rumgammeln.
genau. Und warten darauf, dass eine bestimmte Zielsignatur auftaucht. Also entweder, dass halt irgendwie ihnen ein Zielmanuell zugewiesen wird oder dass sie zum Beispiel sowas wie einen Panzer sehen, der halt eine bestimmte Radarsignatur, eine bestimmte optische Signatur hat und fallen dann darauf oder zum Beispiel ein Schiff sich halt in ihre Killbox rein bewegt. Und das ist halt relativ interessant, weil da ist halt die Frage halt, wer fällt denn eigentlich jetzt die Tötungsentscheidung, also wer sozusagen sagt, jetzt mal angreifen, wird dann halt schon optional. Also gerade bei dieser Typhoon-Drohne zum Beispiel ist es so, dass die Fähigkeit, dass das Ding wirklich automatisch agiert, also dass das halt einfach sich auf ein Panzer oder auf ein Schiff stürzt, die wurde halt von vornherein reindesigned. Und dann bekam da doch irgendjemand bauchschmerzen, zumindest irgendwie für die Bundeswehr. Und dann wurde entschieden, dass das Projekt abgewandelt wird und es so gebaut wird, dass halt die finale Angriffsentscheidung halt immer noch wieder von den Menschen gefällt wird. Also dass das Ding halt einen Link nach hause hat und halt irgendwie sagt, jetzt hier, da ist mein Ziel, und jetzt will ich da mal. Und der Mensch halt noch irgendwie fünf Sekunden Zeit hat, nö zu sagen.
Und das ist ja eigentlich schon Makulatur, oder?
Nee, das ist tatsächlich, also das ist momentan der Stand der Dinge so, also dass man halt sagt, naja, also diese Loitering Ammunition.
Wir haben ja gehört damals bei den Laden, dass der ein Satellitentelefon hatte am Anfang und dass er irgendwann gelernt hat, dass man das als Ziel für Raketen nehmen könnte.
genau.
War das irgendwie Urban Legend oder stimmt das technisch?
Also der Hintergrund war, dass die die Russen hatten damals diesen Chechenenführer, wie hieß er?
Äh, ich weiß nicht mehr.
Also jedenfalls gab es da so einen Chechenenführer, der hat halt auch gerne an vier Satellitentelefonen telefoniert.
Und der ist dann mysteriös getroffen worden.
Den haben die, den haben sie tatsächlich mit Raketen getötet. Und da war eine Zeit lang unklar, wie das eigentlich gelaufen ist. Und was sich hinterher herausstellte, wo ist wohl, dass sie seinen Satellitentelefon halt manuell aus dem Flugzeug angepeilt haben und ihn dann quasi optisch gefunden haben, also halt hingeflogen sind und halt ihn da irgendwie im Feld haben, hocken sehen. Aber eine Zeit lang hieß es, dass sie sich Anti-Radar-Raketen umgebaut haben. Also das heißt, so Raketen, die eigentlich dafür da sind, wenn du halt ein Luftabwehrsystem angreifst, dann programmierst du Raketen auf die Radarfrequenzen vom Gegner. Und was die Rakete halt tut, die fliegt halt dahin, wo das Radar ist und zerstört halt das Radar. Und eine Zeit lang hieß es halt, also so was halt, eines der Gerüchte, dass die Russen halt einfach so genau so eine Rakete genommen haben und die auf die Ablenkfrequenz von einem Satellitentelefon umprogrammiert haben. Sodass sie halt nicht mal genau wissen mussten, wo er ist.
Na gut, das ist aber scheiße von mir als einer Subscriber.
Schießt die halt schon grob in die Richtung. Und da hieß es dann, also wurde dann aber eine Weile hin und her diskutiert, da sind in den üblichen Expertenforen, bis denn jemand meinte so, er hält es für relativ unwahrscheinlich, weil die Sendeleistungen so klein sind. Also dass man die halt vermutlich nicht, also dass es halt vermutlich technisch schlicht nicht funktionieren würde. Aber gut, auf jeden Fall zur Zeit lang war halt der klar, dass es halt möglicherweise ein automatisches Target-Ding gibt. Klar ist halt, so ein Satellitentelefon kannst du immer targeten. Also es ist halt immer den Ablink in deiner Funk-Aufklöre und kannst dann dementsprechend halt irgendwie bekämpfen.
Aber eine Zielvorstellung ist das schon für sowas wie Loitering Ammunition, dass du sagst, du lässt irgendwie so ein Teil kreisen und wenn irgendwie die Zielperson ihr Handy anschaltet, dann macht's boom.
genau, also dass man halt zum Beispiel die E-Mail eines Telefons halt als Zielsignatur benutzt, ist durchaus auch nicht auszuschließen. Also gerade wenn man so eine Kombination von Drohnen denkt, die zum Beispiel halt eine Stadt oder ein Viertel oder so überwacht, um zu gucken, ob dann ein bestimmtes Telefon online kommt. Ein Terrorist! Um dann halt irgendwie kleinere Drohnen loszuschicken, die halt irgendwie das Telefon suchen bzw. dann halt möglicherweise hinterher noch eine Gesichtserkennung dahinter schneiden. Dann ist halt interessant, ne? Also wenn man es so erzählt, so völlig neutral erzählt, dann ist es halt, denkt man so, okay, es bestimmt was, mit dem ich es hier eh irgendwie fiese Terroristen ausschalten will. Wenn man es andersherum erzählen würde und sagen würde, und dann nehmen wir mal irgendwie so eine Stadt, nehmen wir mal Washington oder so.
Wir waren noch alle bei den Tschechien, das passt doch perfekt.
genau, nehmen wir nochmal Washington oder so und dann programmiert man da halt die E-Mail-Nummer von irgendeiner Zielperson hinein und dann wird die Zielperson vernichtet. So, ne? Und dann schon hat man halt irgendwie einen fiesen Terroranschlag. Also die Technologie ist auf beiden Seiten verwendbar. Das ist eben auch die interessante Frage, wohin geht dann die Reise mit diesen Drohnen? Weil, was wir momentan haben, sind ja, also im militärischen Bereich haben, ist quasi ein Flugzeugersatz. Also quasi die momentan rumfliegenden Drohnen.
Auch von der Größe her, mehrere Meter Spannbreite und so.
Es gibt da einen ganzen Zoo, also es fängt halt an von so kleinen Handtellergroßen an Teilen, die man halt irgendwie so mal in den Flur runterschickt. Über so Modellflugzeuggroße Dinger, die man benutzt, um so eine Base mal abzusichern. Geht weiter über so ein bisschen größer als Chessner, halt so diese Predator-Klasse oder halt irgendwie dann jetzt die neueste Generation, halt die Reaper oder die Warrior oder die Grey Eagle. Das sind halt so Drohnen. Da hängen halt so sowas wie vier Hellfire drunter. Also da sind halt so Bodenluftraketen, die halt ursprünglich zur Panzerbekämpfung gebaut wurden oder mittlerweile tatsächlich auch Stinger, also Luftluftraketen, die zum Abschießen von anderen Drohnen oder Flugzeugen gedacht sind. Bis hin dann zu solchen Drohnen wie die Global Hawk. Das ist halt eine riesige, riesige Dinge. Das hat die Spannweite von so einer 747. Und das ist halt ein, also wirklich monströs groß und kann halt ab 8,5.
Sieht doch aus wie so eine Boeing.
Ja, ist auch von Boeing. Und kann halt 48 Stunden fliegen. So, also das heißt, sie kann halt um die Welt fliegen.
Weil die einfach sehr leicht beladen ist oder wie?
Nee, weil die sind, also die hat ein riesiges Flügelspannweite zu Gewichtverhältnissen, Segler. Das Ding hat zwar ein Triebwerk.
Also ist ja leichter, weil auch nicht irgendwie Passagiere rumfliegen muss und Gepäck.
Naja, die ist nicht vom Gewicht leicht. Die ist halt schon ein ziemlicher Trum.
Ja, aber im Vergleich zu einem Flügelspannweite.
genau, das ist halt das Problem. Also dazwischen spannt sich halt so diese Bandbreite der modernen Flugdrohne auf.
Wie groß ist denn so ein Loitering Ammunition Time? Ist das auch ein Chessner von der Große oder ein Teiler?
Eher kleiner. Also diese Taifun-Drohne, die ist halt so wie so ein Smart in der Größenklasse. Ein bisschen schmaler halt so.
Ja gut, das ist aber auch relativ massiv.
So von der Länge halt so, also nicht jetzt vom Flug. Also das ist halt so ein relativ kompaktes Ding und die soll ja auch billig sein, das ist ja nur one way.
Ja, aber das finde ich überhaupt so ein Punkt bei diesen Drohnen. Meine naive Vorstellung war immer, naja, das lohnt sich ja nur, wenn die richtig billig sind. Und ich dachte da so Größenordnung irgendwie 10k. Aber wenn du dir anguckst, was die für so eine Drohne ausgeben, das ist ja eher im Millionenbereich. Also jetzt reine Herstellung, Material, jetzt gar nicht mal die Forschungskosten. Wenn du die mit einrechnest, dann bist du gleich bei irgendwie dreistelligen Millionen.
Also eine Global Hawk kostet so 35 Millionen. Gut, das ist ja auch Flyaway-Kosten. Also das ist halt sozusagen die Oberklasse.
Die ist aber auch nicht zum irgendwie abstürzenden One-Way gedacht, sondern die soll ja irgendwie auch so kommen.
Also jetzt zum Vergleich, also wenn man halt so sich so anguckt, so aktuelle moderne Kampfflugzeuge, die sind halt eher so in der 150 bis 250 Millionen Dollar pro Unit-Klasse. So das heißt, wir haben da halt eher so ein Faktor 5 oder so, weil das Ding billiger ist.
Hat Global Hawk Raketen oder ist das eher so eine Fernsteuer?
Die Global Hawk ist eine Radar- und Aufklärungstrone. Also die dient halt dazu, einfach einen Radar da oben hin zu haben, so wie beim AVEX, aber auch bodenaufklärung zu machen.
Sind die Radar-Kosten schon drin oder ist das nur die blanke Drohne?
Das sind so die Flyaway-Kosten.
Also komplett. Na gut, dann ist das aber gar nicht so hoch. So eine Radar-Kost ist auch eine lange Kohle.
Und so eine Predator, die kosten so, beziehungsweise die Predator, die Reaper, also die aktuelle Drohnen-Generation, die kostet in der Größe von zwischen 8 und 11 Millionen je nach Ausstattung, aber das ist halt System-Preis.
Davon kommen noch Dings dazu.
Nee, nee, System-Preis heißt es komplett. Also Drohne plus alles drum und dran.
Aber ohne Fernsteuercenter.
Inklusive Fernsteuercenter. Oh. genau. Es wird halt schon deutlich preiswerter, als wenn du jetzt irgendwie überlegst, du müsstest halt irgendwie da so eine A10 hinschicken oder so ein F22 oder so.
In Größenordnung 200 Millionen oder was kostet die?
So 150 bis 200 Millionen. Und also die Drohnen sind halt interessant, also gerade so halt diese Predator-Klasse, die jetzt ja in großen Mengen eingesetzt wird. Daran wird halt auch diese Economy, die sie da drinnen haben, klar. Also die fliegen zum Beispiel mit einem Flugzeugmotor, der von einer deutschen Firma gebaut wird und zwar die Firma Thielert. Und was die gemacht haben, ist, die haben einen Dieselmotor genommen, also halt so Fahrzeugtechnik quasi und haben den halt für Jetfuel umgebaut, also für Flugzeugfuel. Und so ein aktueller Fahrzeugdieselmotor ist, was so die Zuverlässigkeit angeht, so Faktor 10 über normalen Flugzeugmotoren. Also was halt so Verschleiß und irgendwie, wie oft das Ding halt mal in die Wartung muss und irgendwie so ist. Das heißt also, die sind halt explizit dafür gebaut, lange zu fliegen und auch von einer Effizienz her. genau und halt irgendwie wenig zu verbrauchen. Und das ist halt so die Denke, die halt in diese Drohnen geht. Die sollen halt lange fliegen, also es ist halt so mindestens 12 Stunden eher länger, ohne dass du sie tanken musst und ja, möglichst preiswert sein, weil die Dinger gehen halt einfach kaputt. Ich meine, die fliegen halt einfach. Also die Unfälle, die die haben sind...
Nicht nur über den Iran.
Nein, nein, nein. Also die Unfälle, die die haben, also das ist jetzt 2009, haben sie einen Loss of Control bei so einer Reaper-Drohne. Die Dinger werden ja ferngesteuert und zwar in einer Art und Weise, die man sich so vorstellen kann wie so ein Verkehrsflugzeug. Also ein Verkehrsflugzeug, wenn du da einen Autopiloten programmierst, dann programmierst du da Wegpunkte rein. Das heißt, du sagst jetzt hier starten, dann fliegst du den Wegpunkt an. An dem Punkt fliegst du links, an der Position rechts, dann fliegst du 500 Kilometer geradeaus, dann fliegst du links, dann fliegst du da runter, dann ist die Flughöhe, dann gehst du wieder runter und dann landest die Landung ein. So ist halt diese Programmierung von so einem Verkehrsflugzeug. genauso werden halt diese Drohnen auch gesteuert. Das heißt, die können zwar die Dinge mehr oder weniger live fliegen, also das heißt sozusagen, haben dann noch so ein Joystick.
Du hast doch mal eine barbarische Latenz. Also aus Amerika, das war ja immer so die Story, die sie in der Presse erzählt haben, dass irgendwo in Virginia gibt es eine Tonhalle, wo irgendwie die Drohnenkontroll-Joystick-Fachkräfte sitzen und die Drohne fliegt dann in Kandahar herum. Aber wenn man sich überlegt, inklusive Satelliten-Latenz, zwei bis drei Sekunden hast du ja. Das ist barbarisch. Also von wegen in Echtzeit kämpfen kannst du mal knicken. Das geht nur, wenn du irgendwie ein stationäres Ziel hast oder wenn der, den du angreifst, nicht damit rechnet.
Ja, also deswegen brauchen sie halt ja immer mehr auch eine Autorämie in diese Drohnen ein, also.
Na und, sie verschieben diese Kontrollzentren teilweise in die Länder. Also man hört jetzt davon, dass sie in Afghanistan Militärbasen haben mit Drohnenfernsteuerendpunkten.
Das tun sie auch.
Ah, das was mit der Latenz zu tun, oder? Geht das immer noch über den Satellit oder haben die dann irgendwie eine Funkstrecke?
Also du kannst halt, wenn du ein Flugzeug als Relay benutzt, also du hast dann halt irgendwie eine Drohne oder ein Flugzeug, was oben einfach nur kreist über deiner Base. Damit du möglichst hohe Antennenpositionen hast. Da kannst du halt für die Drohne da parken. Dann kannst du halt so 400, 500 Kilometer Range erzielen, also eher 400 als 500 Kilometer. Das heißt also für das unmittelbare Umfeld hast du dann halt deine Latenz runter auf ein paar Hundert Milliliter. Also das ist mit den Sekunden nicht ganz so.
Das ist immer noch scheiße so nach irgendwie Quake, aber so für Drohnenfernsteuern geht es halt so.
Aber zum Beispiel halt die Art und Weise, wie so Targeting funktioniert, ist ja so, du hast halt zwei, drei Sekunden Delay. Du guckst halt immer in die Vergangenheit. Deswegen haben halt die Kameras in diesen Drohnen sogenannte Optical Tracker Funktionen. Das heißt also der Drohnenoperator, also in der Regel sind es zwei, also es ist ein Pilot und ein Missionoperator, markiert in dem Videobild ein Objekt. Der sagt halt, das hier ist unser Zielobjekt, das ist das Auto oder die Person oder was auch immer.
Und die Kamera folgt ihm dann.
Oder eine Position, also sagt halt hier dieses haus ist halt die Position. Und die Kamera bleibt da drauf. Also die Trägt ist optisch und bleibt da drauf. Und parallel geschaltet mit der Kamera ist der Laser Designator. Der ist also quasi ein Laser, der auf dem Punkt bleibt, wo die Kamera hin zeigt. Und dadurch können sie halt mit diesem D-Laser halbwegs umgehen, dass sie sagen, okay, das hier ist unser Ziel. Auch wenn es ein Auto ist, dann müssen sie das nur einmal der Kamera sagen, das hier ist das Ziel, dann bleibt die Kamera da drauf. Und der Laser bleibt auch mit drauf. Und die Hellfire fliegt dann halt dem Laser hinterher.
Also wer sich mal mit mobilem Internet beschäftigt hat, der weiß auch, dass es da bandbreiten Limits gibt. Und wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, so eine Drohne mit Echtzeit-Video-Feed, also was wenig bekannt ist vielleicht, ist, dass dieses HDTV mit irgendwie MPEG und so, das kommt vom Militär ursprünglich. Also die Kompressionen, die wir heute im Konsumerbereich benutzen, die kommen vom Militär. Aber trotzdem gibt es ja ein Limit darauf, wie viele Video-Streams du parallel irgendwie per Funk übertragen kannst. Was ist denn da so das Limit? Wie viele Drohnen kannst du denn parallel in Betrieb haben oder tricksten die da irgendwie?
Das ist völlig unklar. Also klar ist halt nur, dass sie halt zu wenig Bandbreite haben. Also die mieten halt irgendwie regulär alles, was irgendwie da so an ziviler Übertragungskapazität in diesem Bereich verfügbar ist, um halt irgendwie ihre Feats darüber zu kriegen. Im lokalen Bereich haben die Drohnen teilweise einen Direct-Downlink. Das heißt also, die Drohnen, wenn du halt keinen ernsthaften Gegner hast, der halt die Drohne dann abschießen könnte, dann knipsen sie den an. Das heißt also, da ist quasi ein DVB-Sender drin. Nichts anderes ist das, ne? Oder sie machen halt Satellite Rebroadcast. Das heißt also, das Video-Signal wird nicht nur nach hause geschickt, sondern wird auf einem zweiten Kanal direkt auf einen Satelliten oben, der ist direkt aufs selbe Gebiet herunterrebroadcastet gesendet, sodass Leute, die unten sind, also was weiß ich, wenn irgendwelche Special Forces-Leute da eben gebüschlauern und ein Bild von der Drohne brauchen, die halt irgendwie fünf Kilometer höher fliegt, dann kriegen sie das halt entweder direkt von der Drohne oder halt vom Satelliten zurückgebeamt. Da gibt es halt diese beiden Möglichkeiten. Aber klar ist halt, die Bandbreite, die sie haben, da jammern sie halt drüber. Das ist halt auch einer der Gründe, warum sie da immer mehr Autonomie fordern.
Das ist jetzt auch tatsächlich technisch begründet und nicht nur irgendwie wir jammern jetzt, weil wir mehr Geld brauchen.
Naja, ist halt schwer zu sagen. Man könnte halt sagen, okay, wir wollen jetzt keine Autonomie, also wir wollen euch die Autonomie nicht geben, weil wir dem nicht vertrauen. Dann sagen die, gut, dann kauft uns mehr Satelliten. Also ist halt die Logik. Wir sind da halt in so einer Spirale drin, dass man sagt, okay, wenn wir jetzt die Drohnen bewaffnen, brauchen wir zuverlässige Kontrolle darüber. Oder wir brauchen mehr Autonomie, weil dann muss die Drohne selber das Richtige tun können. Also es ist halt interessant auch in dieser Diskussion jetzt gerade, die die Bundeswehr da angestoßen hat. Demisir hat ja gesagt, wir wollen halt auch irgendwie die Reaper haben.
Wir wollen mitspielen.
Die Drohnen, die halt irgendwie mit Raketen bewaffnet sind. Und sagt halt, naja, wir haben doch bewaffnete Flugzeuge, da wollen wir doch auch Drohnen haben, die bewaffnet sind.
Aber die Predator ist doch auch bewaffnet, oder nicht?
Ja, die Predator ist aber so eine Ranflanschoption. 2000 haben sie mal festgestellt, dass sie die Flügel stärker gebaut haben, als sie irgendwie hätten sein müssen. Und haben dann halt noch so ein Ding herangemacht. Die eigentlichen Drohnen, die sie jetzt verkaufen, sind halt die Reaper, also die aufgerüstete Version, die sie jetzt überall da einsetzen, in Afghanistan und Pakistan. Die interessante Frage, die dann daraus kommt, natürlich ist halt, was macht ihr denn damit? Also wenn man sich anguckt, was in Pakistan, Afghanistan und Jemen auch zum Beispiel in Südamerika passiert, in Kolumbien, ist halt vollkommen klar, dass diese Drohnen Mittel der Terrorkriegsführung geworden sind. Dieses ganze Gerede von, das ist doch irgendwie alles chirurgisch und wir irgendwie schießen auch dann nur so ein paar Taliban, die wir eindeutig identifiziert haben, ab, ist totaler Bullshit. Das ist halt so richtig doll gelogen. Und was man halt unterscheiden muss, ist, die Amerikaner haben ja zwei Drohnenflotten. Die haben eine militärische Drohnenflotte, die wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwie, wo sie versuchen nach Roles of Engagement vorzugehen und irgendwie zumindest irgendwie einen Prozess haben, wie halt ihr Target-Ding funktioniert, wo man sagen könnte, nachher möglicherweise geben sie sich wenigstens Mühe, dass es nicht gar so scheiße ist. Und dann gibt es halt die Flotte, die unter der Kontrolle der CIA ist.
Und da gibt es überhaupt keine Kontrolle.
Und die interessiert sich halt im Scheißdreck. Also da gibt es jetzt gerade diesen Bericht hier, Living on the Drones aus Pakistan. Das ist halt total gruselig, weil die Leute sagen halt, okay, das ist nicht so, dass die einmal eine Woche eine Drohne hören oder so, wo die dann mal vorbeifliegt, sondern fünf oder zehnmal am Tag. So und die wissen halt nicht jedes Mal, wenn sie diese Drohne hören. Bin ich das jetzt programmiert, oder ist das das haus von meinem Nachbarn?
Du weißt aber, dass im Nachhinein die rechte Hand bin Lahnz gewesen ist, oder?
Das ist immer die rechte Hand bin Lahnz gewesen oder mindestens eine Ansammlung höchstgefährlicher Taddybahnen. Also da gab es auch Berichte halt irgendwie, auch Al-Dazira, wie das Targeting da funktioniert. Und das ist halt teilweise archaisch. Also die haben da Informanten vor Ort und die kriegen Infrarotmarkierer. Das sind halt so Klumpen, die bestellen halt so einen ja durchlässigen Kunststoff. Und da ist eine Infrarotleuchtdiode drinne, die in einer bestimmten Sequenz blinkt. Und dann legen die die ab an dem haus von dem, der der Taliban ist. Was halt im Zweifel der Nachbar ist, der ihnen irgendwie ihren Esel schief angeguckt hat. Oder was auch immer.
Und dann kommt die Müllabfuhr.
Und dann kommt halt irgendwann die Drohne und es macht bumm. So und das ist halt, man muss sich jetzt mal versuchen, plastisch vorzustellen, wie du in so einer Gesellschaft zu leben, wo du nicht weißt.
Dein Nachbar mag dich nicht, dann hast du verloren.
Ja, so und das führt halt dazu, dass da teilweise sich Dörfer entvölkern, weil die Leute einfach weggehen, weil es einfach nicht mehr auszuhalten ist. So und das ist halt diese Art von Kriegführung, die Drohnen halt möglich machen. Also natürlich könnte man genau das selber auch mit bemannten Flugzeugen machen. Aber das würde man nicht tun, weil es viel zu teuer ist und weil da Piloten drin sitzen, die sich irgendwann fragen, warum mache ich jetzt hier gerade die 55. Lebenshütte platt, wo hinterher dann irgendwie ein benladensrechter Handring gewesen ist. Und zu dem halt möglicherweise dann noch dazu führt, dass die pakistanische Luftwaffe hinter ihnen her ist.
Das ist ja auch so ein Punkt, dass diese Einsätze zum Gutteil nicht in Afghanistan, sondern in Pakistan sind.
Zum großen Teil.
Ja und das Pakistan.
Oder in Jemen oder Kolumien.
Ja, aber jedenfalls in anderen Ländern als denen, wo offiziell ein Konflikt ist und Krieg erklärt ist, sowieso nicht worden. Ja, die Zeiten sind vorbei. Das heißt, wir haben hier, das ist die nächste Iteration in der Aufweichung des Kriegserklärens. Ja, dass man heute einfach nicht mal mehr, also Krieg erklärt man schon lange nicht mehr, aber heute, wenn man seine Armee in Afghanistan stationiert, heißt es eben auch nicht, dass man die Grenzen respektiert, sondern man bombt eben wild in anderen Ländern rum und man hat auch perfekte Deniability, wie man so schön sagt. Also früher gab es noch dieses Problem, als die U2 über Russland abgeschossen wurde, dass sie den Piloten gefangen nehmen konnten und befragen konnten. Er hat zwar nicht viel gesagt, aber er konnte schlecht leugnen, dass er ein Ami ist. Dass er ein Ami ist, ja, aber das ist mit den Drohnen eben vorbei, zumal auch, dass da große Proliferationen gibt. Also diese Predator ist ein Exportschlager, die Israelis sind noch relativ gut.
Zumal, dass es keine richtige Rocket Science ist. Also es ist halt so, dass die Iraner zum Beispiel, die hatten schon zu Zeiten, als sie noch gegen den Irak gekämpft haben, hatten die schon eigene Drohnen, diese Moja hier, Drohnen, die sie mittlerweile in der vierten Interaktion bauen. Und das war halt, naja, gut, die haben halt nur 50 Kilometer Range gehabt und konnten nur 1,5 Stunden lang fliegen.
Na, was heißt nur, das reicht doch, wenn du deinen Nachbarn gehörst.
Aber mittlerweile sind die halt eben auch bei sieben Stunden und die können irgendwie 15.000 Fuß und 150 Kilometer weit fliegen. Das ist also schon richtig ernstzunehmender Hardware. Und interessant ist, dass die zumindest, was so die Geschichtsschreibung angeht, möglicherweise die Iraner, die ersten waren, die tatsächlich eine bewaffnete Drohne gebaut haben. Und zwar gibt es Berichte darüber, dass die halt im Irakkrieg, also Iran gegen Irak, das ist schon mal richtig eine Weile her, dass sie da so apg-7-panzerfaust-dinger unter die Drohnen drunter geschnallt haben, um dann damit Bodenziele anzugreifen. Also quasi genauso, wie die Amis dann halt mit den Predator-Drohnen gemacht haben, die halt eigentlich auch erst eine Aufklärungsdrohne waren und dann gedacht haben, ach, da kann man noch was drunter schneiden. genauso haben es die Iraner damals schon gemacht. Das heißt aber, was wir da sehen, ist halt, die Proliferation dieser Technologie ist de facto nicht aufzuhalten.
Ist schon zu spät auch, ne? Also eigentlich jeder, jeder von dem man nicht will, dass der es hat, hat es schon.
Ja, oder kann es halt haben. Ich meine, es halt, also wenn du überlegst die Sensoren und die Prozess-Leistungen, die du halt irgendwie in so einer handvoll moderner Smartphones drin hast, ist es vollständig ausreichend, um so eine Drohne zu fliegen.
Da wollte ich vorhin noch was sagen. Also es gibt so ein witziges Detail bei Smartphones, wenn man da, wenn das Smartphone detectet, dass es schneller als wieviel Warntes 1000 kmh fliegt oder so.
Na ja, 900.
900, dann schaltet sich das GPS aus, weil sie eben verhindern wollen, dass sie in handgebastelten Cruise Missiles benutzt werden.
Ist tatsächlich eine Regelung, die in allen zivilen GPS-Empfängern drin ist. Also es ist halt eine Vorschrift, die, wenn du halt GPS-Empfänger bauen willst, die halt GPS empfangen, dann musst du dich daran halten. Also das ist tatsächlich in diese Chipsets reingebaut. Die kann man auch trivial rauspatchen. Das ist halt nur irgendwie eine Zeit in der Firmware.
Ja, darum geht's ja nicht. Aber dass es überhaupt sowas gibt, finde ich einfach schon sehr bemerkenswert.
Ich hab natürlich drüber nachgedacht. GPS ist natürlich für den bau von Bastel-Drohnen oder Drohnen, die von den Amis nicht gemocht werden, natürlich problematisch. Man kann natürlich hingehen und einfach in ein großes Modellflugzeug einen entsprechenden Autopiloten und GPS einbauen. Da hat eine technologisch überhaupt nichts dran. Es gibt keinerlei Technologie hin. Das ist halt nur reine Entwicklung.
Und wie viel Payload würde man denn brauchen, um so ein haus zu springen? Das ist ja auch nicht viel mit einem Kilo. Also, wenn du davon ausgehst, dass du gut treffst, was kostet denn so eine Bombe? Oder wie, also jetzt gewichtsmäßig, was kostet denn so eine?
Also wir können ja mal gucken.
Wenn du so eine Basteldrohne bauen solltest, die ein haus springen kann in 100 Kilometer Entfernung, was würdest du schätzen? 20 Pfund? Na ja, gut, 10 Kilo. Also 10 Kilo ist doch ein Bereich, was Basteldrohnen erreichen können.
Das ist halt so eine, wer hat sowas wie, ich glaube sowas wie 2,50 Meter Spannweite, 2 Meter würde er wahrscheinlich hinkommen.
Das sind jetzt die Hellfire Raketen?
genau, das ist halt eine Hellfire. Also nur mal so eine Referenz zu haben, wie halt der. Also eine Hellfire hat einen Sprengkopf zwischen 8 und 9 Kilogramm.
Also die Frage, die mich immer beschäftigt hat bei diesen Hellfire Raketen ist, wenn man überhaupt diese Art von Munition, die die da verschießen, dass die für ihre Munition schon mehr ausgeben, als ich für ein Auto ausgeben würde. So eine Hellfire, was steht da gerade? 88.000 Dollar kostet eine fucking Rakete, mit der sie einen Esel sprengen und dann danach war es ein Taliban Esel. Und wenn ich jetzt eine Bastel-Drohne baue und die kostet nur 10.000 Dollar, dann kann ich doch so ökonomisch einen Krieg führen gegen Land. Wenn ich die zwinge, mit ihren viel teureren Abwehrraketen meine Drohnen abzuballern, das ist doch die Strategie, die man anwenden würde gegen sowas. Oder, dass einfach deine Drohnen so billig sind, dass sich der Abschluss nicht rentiert.
Da gab es gerade so eine interessante Zahl, da setzt es halt voraus, dass deine Wirtschaft gleich groß ist.
Ja gut, klar, das stimmt natürlich.
Also das ist halt irgendwie jetzt, wenn du mal so Iran versus US setzt, die Amis haben halt so ein Offensive-Budget von ungefähr einer Trillion Dollar.
Das ist so unglaublich. Es gab neulich so eine Darstellung, wenn man, so als Gegenüberstellung, wenn man allen Studenten in den USA ihre Uni-Gebühren zahlen wollte, das wären irgendwie, was haben die ausgerechnet, 75 Milliarden Dollar. Und das entspricht zufällig dem Teil des Pentagon-Budgets, was für unaccounted waste rausgeht. Also gar nicht mal Waste, den sie beziffern könnten, wo irgendwie das war der Out dafür und das hat halt nicht geklappt, sondern einfach Kram, so was irgendwie in den Sofa-Ritzen verschwunden ist. Ja, da kann natürlich niemand mithalten, dass dir nichts was ging.
genau, deswegen ist halt irgendwie dieser Price tag ist da. Die wollen natürlich schon sparen, aber das ist halt, also sagen wir, im Faktor 6 oder so kommst du da nicht gegen an. Aber die interessante Frage, die dahinter steht, ist ja eigentlich tatsächlich diese Drohnenproliferation. Wozu führt denn das? Also wo werden wir denn eigentlich damit hinkommen? Und das ist halt ein nicht besonders schöner Ausblick. Also da, wenn man sich das anguckt, da landet man halt schon in so einer Shadowrun-Welt dabei.
Na überhaupt, die Barbarisierung haben wir ja schon angesprochen. Es gibt noch einen anderen Aspekt an der Barbarisierung, den ich sehr wichtig finde, den man bei sich selbst beobachten kann. Finde ich ein schöner Vergleich ist der Spam-Filter. Weil da ist mir das bei mir selbst aufgefallen. Wenn man den zum ersten Mal programmiert, dann traut man ihm noch nicht und guckt immer mal, was hat er denn getaggt. Und dann fängt man an und der lernt. Und man traut ihm immer mehr. Und nach ein paar Jahren guckt man einfach nur noch irgendwie einmal im Monat, wenn überhaupt, in seinen Spam-Folder rein. Und das ist bei den Drohnen natürlich genauso. Wenn man jetzt sagt, man hat noch einen Menschen, der auf Abschuss drückt, dann muss man sich vor Augen halten, dass so eine Drohne irgendwie drei, vier Video-Feeds hat, ein Radar-Feed, die Daten kann eine Person überhaupt gar nicht in Echtzeit beobachten, die da reinkommen. Das heißt, wir haben schon eine Vorselektion der Realität, anhand derer entschieden wird, durch irgendwelche Algorithmen. Und der Mensch, der ist nur noch da, damit man moralisch rechtfertigen kann, dass man jetzt abgeschossen hat. Man sagt, da war aber noch ein Mensch und er hätte Nein sagen können. Aber realistisch gesehen wird das so eine Abstumpfung geben, wie bei dem Spam-Filter, nicht?
Ja, exakt genau. Das wird befürchtet, dass es passiert.
Kann man das schon sehen?
Ja, also wir haben jetzt schon die Situation, dass gerade im Grenzgebiet der Afghanistan-Pakistan, dass es Angriffe mit Drohnen gab auf Leute, wo Pattern-Matching-Algorithmen auf den Videofeeds gesagt haben, die sehen aus wie Taliban.
Von welcher Auflösung reden wir denn da?
Na ja, so Infrarot-Kameras mit irgendwie 720p ist halt so der Standard in diesen Drohnen. Aus der Luft?
Da kannst du doch gerade mal erkennen, dass sich ein Mensch handelt.
Naja, je nachdem, wie viel Zoom du da dran hast.
Wie im Moment, die sagen dann, hat ein Torbahn, kommt weg oder wie?
Naja, die arbeiten nach Bewegungspatterns. Du kannst halt erkennen, die bewegen da Kram. Also die haben da sieht aus wie Waffenkisten.
Also entweder da zieht jemand um oder ist das Taliban und wir bomben jetzt mal.
Na ja, vielleicht ein bisschen komplizierter, aber so in der großen Klasse, genau.
Krasse Scheiße.
Wenn du halt irgendwie, also in dem Fall war es halt so, das war halt eine Gruppe von Menschen, die sich da durchs Gebirge bewegt hat. Und Better Matching hat gesagt, offensichtlich ist das halt ein Taliban-Munitionsversorgungsweg. Die haben da halt irgendwie längliche Kisten auf den Eseln.
Oder ist das ein Bergsteiger, der Scherpas dabei hat?
Nee, in dem Fall waren es halt einfach Schmuggler, die halt einfach irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was sie da geschmuggelt haben, jedenfalls keine Waffen. Und dann wurden die halt einfach mit den Drohnen ermordet. Dann haben sie sich hinterher, der Vatrian, schuldigt, der ist üblicher, aber diese Mechanismen, die werden halt immer üblicher. Interessant daran ist aber, dass die, irgendjemand entwickelt das ja. Also irgendjemand schreibt diese Software und muss das ja in Betrieb nehmen und warten und irgendwie weiterentwickeln. Und da gibt es tatsächlich eine ganze Klasse von Informatikern. durchaus auch welche, die, wollen wir jetzt sagen, möglicherweise glauben die von sich ja auch durchaus ein Verantwortungsbewusstsein zu haben. Die sagen so, jaja, das ist ein Problem der jetzigen Technik, aber wenn wir einmal fertig sind mit unserer tollen Artificial Intelligence, die wir dafür verwenden wollen, dann wird es besser.
Das finde ich die gruseligste Vorstellung überhaupt, dass es am Ende tatsächlich irgendein Artificial Intelligence Ding ist und nicht programmiert. Denn das nimmt mir als Programmierer den letzten Grund, mich schuldig zu fühlen, daran, dass irgendwas schief geht, wenn es nicht ich war, sondern die Software hat es gelernt. Und ich frage mich sowieso, wie solche Leute nachts schlafen können.
Die glauben, die machen die Welt besser.
Wie kannst du denn damit schlafen, dass deine Software hat Leute ermordet? Das ist doch dasselbe, als wenn du mit einer Pistole rumrennst. Ich sehe den Unterschied.
Deswegen benutzen sie AI-Konzepte, wo sie sagen, das war nicht meine Software, sondern nur die AI, die zufällig...
Die Entscheidung, das eine zu setzen, hat jemand anderes gemacht?
Ja, super. Ich habe doch hier nur die Software gespielt.
Ja, toll. Eine Sache, die ich an der Stelle sehr wichtig finde, ist, dass die Forscher gar nicht alle mit dem Ziel arbeiten, jetzt Kampffrohnen zu bauen, sondern dass die sich Sachen einreden. Und eine Analogie, die an der Stelle gerne verwendet wird, ist, dass man sagt, wir bauen aber Rettungsdrohnen. Also jetzt nicht Flugdrohnen.
Search and Rescue ist das.
Search and Rescue ist so der Term, den man da benutzt. Das sind halt irgendwie so Volley-Style-Roboter, oder Flugdrohnen, die sich halt durch Terrain bewegen und dann noch lebende Menschen im Gerümpel finden sollen. Aber die Technologie ist natürlich dieselbe. Das ist dasselbe. Wenn du sagst, search, du suchst einen Menschen, ob du denen retten willst oder ob du dann abdrückst, das ist ja völlig peripherere Angelegenheit. Das ist ein anderes Software-Modul. Das Search-Thing ist dual-use. Und daran zu forschen ist schon genauso verwerflich in meinen Augen, wie direkt an einer Suchbombe zu forschen. Deswegen würde ich das auch nie machen, obwohl ich damals angefangen hab, mir mal so ein bisschen eine Rinalde Netze und so anzugucken. Aber wenn man mal durchdenkt, wo das hinführt, was man da gerade forscht. Gesichtserkennung war damals die große Sache. Und da haben auch viele Leute gesagt, ist doch toll, wenn der Computer dein Gesicht erkennen kann. Das kann man irgendwie statt Einloggen benutzen und so. Aber das will man doch gar nicht, dass der Computer das Gesicht erkennen kann. Denn sonst haben wir bald überall Kameras. Und genau so läuft's. Heute haben die Handys Gesichtserkennung drin. Das will man doch alles überhaupt nicht haben.
Und demnächst die Drohnen.
Und da müssen wir mal an der Stelle laut zu aufrufen. Wissenschaftler, denkt da bitte ordentlich und lange drüber nach, was ihr da eigentlich gerade tut.
Also insbesondere gerade im Bereich halt so Mustererkennung und künstliche Intelligenz sind halt so die beiden Felder, die halt gerade in der Drohnenentwicklung extrem wichtig werden. Mustererkennung deswegen, weil dieses Prinzip bei diesen Loitering Ammonitions, also dass man halt einfach Zielkoordinaten bzw. Zielsignaturen von Radar- oder von optischen oder elektronischen Signaturen reinprogrammiert in die Drohne und halt schon ein Großteil des Processings on board macht. Also dass man halt sagt, okay, wir kriegen die Daten nicht alle nach hause, wir kriegen gar nicht die raw Videofeeds nach hause, sondern wir können uns darauf verlassen, dass die Algorithmen in der Drohne rausfinden, welche Teile des Videofeeds gerade interessant sind und uns dann nur genau diesen selektiv ausgewählten Ausschnitt aus unserer Hinschung durch den Strom wahrgenommen Realität übertragen lassen, um daraufhin dann unsere Entscheidung zu fällen oder die eben sogar der Drohne zu überlassen. Deshalb ein Feld, wo gerade eine Menge Geld reinfließt. Und das findet dann halt statt unter ganz harmlosen Sachen, also unter total harmlosen Forschungsbezeichnungen, halt einfach so Mustererkennung. Die kann man natürlich auch einfach für Industrieroboter benutzen. Die kann man natürlich auch genauso verwenden, um rauszukriegen, ob halt irgendwie ein Großteil jetzt gerade noch zu viel Grad dran hat. Das ist halt irgendwie dieselbe Klasse Forschungssystematik, die dahinter steckt. Aber man muss sich halt echt überlegen, wofür man halt irgendwie sein Talent und seine Zeit da einsetzt. Und was auch immer wieder ist unterstreicht, dass wir eigentlich eine Softwarelizenz brauchen, die sich exklusiv nur darum kümmert, dass sie halt nicht für solche Sachen eingesetzt werden darf.
Wir haben vorhin kurz darüber gesprochen, in Berlin gibt es eine relativ breite akademische Basis für Roboterfußball. Und das US-Militär hat die DARPA, das ist eine Organisation, bei der es darum geht, die stellt so Challenges und da gibt es dann für den Gewinner Geld. Und die Challenges sind sowas wie zum Beispiel ein Auto bauen, was sich autonom durch dieses Terrain in Neumexiko bewegen kann. Oder Search and Rescue ist auch so eine Sache, die DARPA ausschreibt. Und dann nehmen dann Uniteams daran teil und nehmen halt am Ende den Cashpreis entgegen, wenn sie gewonnen haben. Aber dass die Technologie dann in irgendwelchen Waffensystemen landet, das will lieber keiner denken. Und da gab es gerade in Berlin so eine Sache, dass ein DARPA-Challenge eben jetzt nicht von…
Diskussionen, das ist noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Gut, aber jedenfalls…
Also jetzt mal kurz erklären, diese DARPA-Challenges. DARPA ist halt die amerikanische Militärforschungsorganisation und die haben den Auftrag halt, ja so sogenannte Blue Sky Technologien fürs Militär zu entwickeln, also dafür zu sorgen, dass das Militär halt immer die tollste Tech hat. Und diese Challenges, also zum Beispiel diese Auto-Challenge, die bringen halt das Feld halt immer schon durchaus voran. Also die haben halt dazu geführt, dass es halt dort nochmal Autos gibt, also aus der DARPA-Challenge für Autos ist und dann in die Google-Car impliziter vorgegangen. Und die nächste DARPA-Challenge zeichnet sich halt wieder genau dadurch aus, dass sie halt erstmal harmlos klingen, nämlich das sogenannte Fukushima-Szenario. Und was da passieren soll, ist, also das Uni-Team soll halt einen bipedalen Roboter, also einen menschenähnlichen, zweieinigen Roboter programmieren, der sich aus einem raum heraus bewegt, in einen Traktor oder ein anderes Fahrzeug einsteigt, mit dem Ding zu einem anderen Building, also zum anderen Gebäude fährt, da aussteigt, durch eine geschlossene Tür mit einem Schlüssel da reingeht, dann sich durch irgendwie so 100 Meter Trümmerfeld in einem Flur bewegt, eine Leiter hochklettert, ein leckendes Rohr lokalisiert, das zudreht, in dem es ein Ventil zudreht und dann eine fehlerhafte Pumpe ersetzt. So, also halt die Idee dahinter ist halt so zu strukturieren, als würde man das Ding...
Als ginge das so an Atomkraftwerk.
genau, bei der nächsten Kernschmelze einsetzen.
Was ja auch ein Blödsinn ist, lustigerweise. Na ja, es kommt drauf an. Also nach Fokuschime, nach Tschernobyl gab es diese Geschichte, dass die Russen da ihr also an sich legendär hartnäckiges Gerät hingeschickt haben. Und die Elektronik ging dann halt kaputt, weil die Strahlung zu hoch war. Ja, also das ist nur, weil es ein Roboter ist, heißt es nicht, dass der von Strahlung nicht betroffen ist. Aber unabhängig davon.
genau, die interessante Frage war ja, wer nimmt denn an den Sachen teil und...
Warte mal, wir sollten vielleicht noch sagen zu dieser Challenge, fast alle von diesen Einzelpunkten sind schon mal von Robotern gelöst worden. Also es gibt ein Roboter-Hand, die eine Tür aufschließen könnte. Ja, die Feinmotorik dafür haben wir. Es gibt Roboter, die du in ein Auto setzt und die dann die Pedale betreten können und die autonom das Fahrzeug lenken können. Es gibt Algorithmen, die ein leckendes Rohr finden könnten. Das wird ja auch in Ölpipelines von Robotern gemacht. Und es gibt Roboter, die so ein Ventil schließen können. Aber das alles zusammen gibt es noch nicht.
genau, und auch nicht in der Qualität, dass es in einem System wirklich funktionsfähig ist.
Aber soweit ist die Robotik. Diese ganzen einzelaufgaben könnten wir machen. Das ist jetzt zwar akut unrealistisch, aber es ist nicht völlig unrealistisch.
genau, also die Leute, die in den Feldern unterwegs sind, gehen davon aus, dass wahrscheinlich bei der ersten Runde von der Challenge es keinen richtigen Sieger geben wird, aber bei der zweiten wahrscheinlich schon. Das heißt, in drei, vier Jahren wird es halt möglich sein. Die interessante Frage ist nun aber, wer nimmt denn daran teil? Und so in Berlin gibt es ja mehrere Universitäten und unter anderem ist da halt die Frage, nehmen jetzt Berliner Universitäten daran teil? Und die Diskussionen, die da gerade laufen, sind sehr spannend, weil zum Beispiel die TU in Berlin hat ja eine sogenannte zivilklausel. Das heißt also, gehört aus der historischen Geschichte heraus, dass die TU ja mal eine Universität war, in der eine Menge Waffenforschung stattgefunden hat, zu Nazi-Zeiten, eine sogenannte zivilklausel. Dass sie sagt, also wir beteiligen uns nicht an militärischen Forschungsprojekten. Und da laufen gerade die Diskussionen sehr heiß, nämlich ob unter dieser zivilklausel eine Teilnahme an so einer Challenge, die halt von der DARPA, und das D steht dafür, Defense und nicht für digital, ob die halt möglich ist. Und da muss man halt mal wieder klar sagen, eigentlich ist es ganz gut, dass es halt genau so was wie diese zivilklausel gibt, weil da kann man sich im Zweifel darauf berufen sagen, nee, wir möchten halt keine Militärforschung machen. Wenn man dieses Fukushima-Szenario halt einmal kurz ein bisschen anders rumdenkt, dann ist das Mission Impossible. Dann ist es halt Mission Impossible. Da geht der Roboter halt da rein und platziert halt die Bombe da oder zappt irgendwie das Kabel an oder bricht.
Macht das Ventil zu, was das Kraftwerk am Leben gehalten hat.
genau wie bei Search and Rescue ist es halt immer nur ein minimaler Unterschied in der Programmierung, ob es jetzt ein Kriegsroboter oder halt ziviler Hilfsroboter ist. Die spannende Frage dabei ist natürlich, wo geht denn dann die Reise hin? Und bisher haben wir halt viel über Roboter geredet, die halt fliegen und die sind natürlich sehr praktisch. Also gerade im Bereich von Planestin-Nissionen hat zum Beispiel merkt man es immer nur wieder daran, wenn halt irgendwo so ein Ding mal runterfällt. Also so ist halt zum Beispiel irgendwie 2011 so eine Reaper auf den Sichellen gecrashed, also mitten im indischen Ozean.
So was hat die da verloren?
genau, was hat die da verloren? Und dann, wenn man sich so anguckt, die Statistiken der Drohnenangriffe, nachdem die Amis bin Laden getötet haben und da seine Festplatten beschlagnahmt haben, haben sie innerhalb von Tagen angefangen, plötzlich mit Drohneinsätzen im Jemen. Es gibt Berichte darüber, dass richtig viele Drohneinsätze mittlerweile in Südamerika, also insbesondere Kolumbien und Peru, stattfinden, um da halt in den Drogenkriegen mitzuspielen. Das heißt also, durch das Durchführen von Klandestinemissionen, dafür sind Drohnen, also insbesondere Flugdrohnen, natürlich extrem geeignet. Aber natürlich wird da nicht aufgehört. Ein Großteil der Entwicklungen, die nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit erfährt wie Flugdrohnen, sind Drohnen, die auf dem Boden eingesetzt werden. Zum Beispiel haben sowohl Südkorea als auch Israel für ihre jeweilige Grenzsicherung mehr oder minder automatische Waffeninstallationen gebaut. Jemand, der sich ein bisschen mit der Geschichte beschäftigt hat, wird sofort an die DDR-Grenze denken. Da gab es nämlich Selbstschussanlagen. Und so eine Selbstschussanlage ist halt, naja, kennt man vielleicht aus Computerspielen, so diese Claymore-Minen, also sind halt irgendwie ein Sprengstoff mit irgendwie einer Menge Hackschrot davor oder auch Kugeln, die ausgelöst werden durch ein Schleupperdraht. Also wenn du halt da langläufst und dann macht es halt bumm und du bist halt irgendwie zerschreddert. Also ist halt so diese automatischen Maschinengewehre, also diese, was Samsung da baut, da sind sie mittlerweile dabei einzubauen, dass es erkennt, wenn jemand auf Anruf und Warnschuss die Hände hebt. Das ist halt sozusagen ihre Art von, wir bauen dann mal so ein bisschen Ethik ein.
Ich traue diesen ganzen Bilderkennungsdinger nicht über den Weg.
Nee, nicht so richtig.
Weil, ich mein, das Problem ist doch, wenn immer du sowas hast, dann kommt diese Beweislastumkehr, wie wir sie aus der EC-Kartenindustrie kennen. Dann heißt es, wieso der hätte nicht geschossen, wenn derjenige die Hände hochgenommen hat. Und damit übrigst dich dann auch eine Untersuchung, ob das jetzt rechtens war oder nicht. Also das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass das ein Fortschritt ist. Ich glaube eher im Gegenteil. In dem Moment, wo du anfängst, solche Dinge einzubauen, wenn die Operator eine viel kleinere Schranke haben, auf den Auslöser zu drücken.
Dazu reicht es schon, wenn der Operator nicht mehr vor Ort ist. Was die Israelis da gebaut haben, ist dieses sogenannte Samson-Torrent. Das ist ein System, das ein schweres Maschinengewehr oder auch weiweißen Granatwerfe enthalten kann und entpacken Kameras und Sensoren. Und die bauen sie auf Turmen entlang der Grenze zum Gazastreifen hin.
Man muss da nur hingehen und die Haare abschneiden. Gut, Bibel-Referenz, lass mir das.
Ja, die Dinge stellen die Dinge halt hin. Und wenn halt die Sensoren da was erfassen, also irgendwie der per Millimeterradar oder per optischen Sensoren, dann dreht sich halt das Maschinengewehr automatisch dahin. Und momentan ist es halt noch so, zumindest angeblich so, dass da halt immer noch ein Remote-Operator auf den Knopf drücken muss, um halt zu feuern. Aber im Prinzip...
Aber sagen wir mal ehrlich, das würde ich doch auch sagen, wenn ich so ein System dahingestellt habe. Egal, ob es jetzt so ist oder nicht, das wäre genau meine Presse-Linie.
Na ja, die interessante Frage ist, wäre das wirklich so? Weil aus Sicht der Israelis ist es doch eigentlich viel abschreckender, wenn sie sagen, nö, das macht es automatisch.
Nein, im Gegenteil. Du willst dir einen Eindruck erwecken, dass da ein Verrückter sitzt, der das auch manuell overriden kann und sagen kann, das da hinten bewegt sich aber auch. Ich finde das nicht... Ich finde, der Punkt ist, also rein aus Taktikgründen musst du immer ansagen, dass es auch einen Menschen gibt. Denn ansonsten hast du diesen Computerspieleffekt. Computerspiele funktionieren im Multiplayer-Bereich häufig so, dass du eben nicht die Person angreifst, sondern seine Strategie. Und wenn du weißt, es ist ein Computer und du hast ein bestimmtes Verhalten beobachtet, dann wirst du deine Strategie so anpassen und du weißt, dass es funktionieren wird. Bei Menschen weißt du das eben nicht. Der Mensch kann irgendwie, wenn er mit einer unvorhergesehenen Sache konfrontiert wird, kann er sich anpassen, der Computer eben nicht. Das heißt, du musst immer ansagen, dass da noch ein Mensch drin sitzt, damit der Feind nicht glaubt, er hat leichtes Spiel, wenn er deinen AI umgehen will.
Naja, bloß wenn du da halt tatsächlich eine AI hast, die halt, also sagen wir mal, nur ein nahes Netz oder irgendwie noch abgefahrenes Zeug, wo du nicht weißt, ob die schon antizipative Strategie ist.
Ob die schon sentient ist oder nicht.
Na gut, okay. Na gut, ja, okay. überhaupt nicht zu weit geht. Aber die halt menschliches Verhalten antizipiert und ist ja für so aktuelle Algorithmen nicht mehr so schwer. Also alles, was du tust, ist Bullshit.
Wieso? Ich glaub kein Wort vor dieser ganzen AI-Scheiße. Weißt du, das Problem ist, du hast entweder die normalen herkömmlichen Algorithmen, da weißt du, was passieren wird. Oder du hast neuronale Netze, da weißt du eben nicht, was passieren wird. Du trainierst den mit deinen Szenarien, mit denen du rechnest, so, dass er so antwortet, wie du möchtest. Aber die Frage ist ja gerade, was passiert, wenn du ein unvorhergesehenes Szenario kriegst. Das kannst du eben nur bedingt vorhersagen, wie ein neuronales Netz dann reagiert. Und deswegen kann Militär das überhaupt nicht einsetzen.
Das würde ich dem Weg immer nicht zustimmen, weil zum einen ist es ja so, dass die Algorithmen, die wir momentan sehen, auch wenn sie jetzt nicht neuronale Netze sind, die halt zum Beispiel große Datenmengen analysieren, die auf menschlichem Verhalten aufbauen, sind in der Lage daraus, Muster zu extrahieren, die ein Mensch nicht sehen kann. Das heißt, es ist tatsächlich irgendwie verhaltenskonglomerate zu finden und verhaltensaufwendigkeiten zu finden, Normalität zu erkennen und abweichend von dieser Normalität zu erkennen.
Ja, da hängt aber kein Menschenleben von ab. Deswegen kann man das machen. Wenn du ein General bist und du musst jetzt verantworten, dass die Software, die du eingesetzt hast, deinen eigenen Operator erschossen hat, weil das neuronale Netz falsch trainiert war, das kann doch keiner verteidigen. Das ist eine Sache, die hatten wir neulich in der Folge mit FX, die fand ich sehr bemerkenswert. Der hat argumentiert, dass die Cyberwar-Geschichten deswegen von den Militären nicht eingesetzt werden, sondern nur defensiv. Also im Großen und Ganzen, dass es diesen Faktor gibt, weil du eben nicht vorher sagen kannst, was alles betroffen sein wird. Und dass dein Arsch on the line ist, wie man sagt. Dass du gefeuert werden kannst, weil deine wildgewordene AI irgendwelche Dinge gemacht hat. Das ist ein Risiko, was ich nicht glaube, was normale Militärs einsetzen werden. Also die Amis, vielleicht, wenn sie in Pakistan irgendwelche Leute bombardieren.
Ich halte jetzt, ich glaube eher, dass das, was wir sehen werden, ist so ein, naja, du weißt ja, es gibt ja diesen Spruch von diesem sowjetischen General Schukow, der gesagt hat, der einfachste Weg, jemanden dazu zu bringen, etwas wirklich Dummes zu tun, ist ihn ein Feigling zu nennen. Und wenn wir uns so angucken, was da so gerade passiert ist, ich hab da gerade vorhin einen Artikel gefunden, dass die Chinesen völlig unerwartet angesagt haben, in irgendeiner Fachzeitschrift, dass sie gerade Drohnen bauen, die mit genetischen Algorithmen, also durchaus selbstladendem Zeug, wo man halt nicht vorher sein kann, was hinten rauskommt, U-Boote jagen. Das heißt also, wo sie halt einfach losgehen, sagen so, wir machen das jetzt.
Wir hatten vorhin ein paar Senden, die Mad Man Strategie, ich glaube, das ist ein Auswuchs davon.
Naja, vielleicht oder auch nicht. Es gibt halt noch einen anderen Hinweis darauf, dass wir halt so einen Wetter in wieviel traus zu dich denn an Autonomität sehen werden. Und zwar es gibt eine gerade eine aktuelle DoD-Studie, also die Partnacht Defense, Autonomie in DoD-Systems, die vom Scientific Board, also halt durchaus Wissenschaftler gemacht wurde da. Und die sagen, naja, also einer der wesentlichen Hindernisse für Autonomie ist zum einen, dass wir da nicht vertrauen. So, also genau, was Fefe sagt und ist aber doof, weil wir müssen darauf vorbereitet sein, dass wir zumindest bei Bodensystemen konfrontiert werden mit einem extrem tödlichen, schnellen, letalen System, was keinerlei irgendwie Einschränkungen hat, also halt irgendwie keine höhere kognitive Funktion, um halt irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass es halt nicht irgendwelche Kriegsrechte oder ähnliche Dinge handelt, sondern halt einfach irgendwie nur alles tötet, was sich bewegt.
Again, Missile Gap 2.0, ja?
genau, und genau das ist es, was wir sehen.
Oh, der Feind ist aber wahnsinnig und irre, und deswegen dürfen wir keine...
Müssen wir genauso irre sein.
Ja, super.
Also wir kommen halt auf einen Weg in diese Autonomie rein, die niemand so richtig vorhergesehen hat, nämlich dass einer gesagt hat, naja, boah, könnte man ja mal machen.
Und wie ist denn das? Autonomie, meinen die damit wirklich die Software und die einzelnen Waffensysteme oder meinen die damit eher sowas wie Sandcom darf unabhängig von Präsidentenentscheidungen bis so und so fehlen?
Na also was die...
Also die meinen doch damit irgendwie so, diese Militärbasis, wenn sie merkt, dass sie von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten ist, dann darf sie aber trotzdem dieses...
Autonomie meint erstmal halt Autonomie der Drohne. Das heißt also, dass der Drohne am Ende, also gibt es halt so eine Klassifizierung in Stufen von Autonomie und wann die wie erreicht werden und so und dann wird auch länglich darüber gestritten, ob es realistisch ist oder ob die Klassifizierung stimmt. Aber im Kern geht es halt darum, am Ende zu sagen, dieser Drohne ist deine Mission. genau wie du heute halt eine Einheit sagst, also irgendwie nimmst du halt dein Platoon von Soldaten oder ein Regiment und sagst, deine Mission ist es, diese Brücke zu verteidigen und dafür zu sorgen, dass der Feind hier nicht rüberkommt. So und alles, was da drunter ist, also was du halt irgendwie, wie du diese Brücke verteidigst oder wie du diese Brücke einnimmst, ist deine Sache.
Weißt du, wie viel schlechte Sci-Fi-Filme mit so einer Prämisse anfangen?
Richtig.
Du hast irgendeine AI und sagst ihr, das ist das Ziel und dann sagt die AI, der einfachste Weg ist, die Menschheit auszurotten.
Yes, sir. Ja, super. So, yes, sir. Menschheit auszurotten. Ja, und da wollen sie halt hin.
Hast du denn den Eindruck, dass die da wirklich hinwollen oder sind das ihr so Technikphilosophen, die sagen, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Nein, also diese Studie ist halt sehr interessant. Also die ist halt ein bisschen länglich, aber wenn man da mal nach Lethal sucht, also noch tödlich, dann findet man halt die interessanten Stellen. Einer davon ist halt, dass, wie sie sagen halt so, sie wollen Lethal Autonomy aus mehreren Gründen. Und einer der Gründe ist, dass in dem Umblick, wo man halt einen drohenden Gegner hat, also einen Gegner, der halt Drohnen ins Feld schickt oder zum Beispiel auch Bodenkampfroboter ins Feld schickt, die nicht behindert werden von irgendwelchen rechtlichen oder sonstigen Erwägungen oder auch nur dem Versuch halt, Kollateralschäden zu vermeiden, sondern halt nur ihre Mission erfüllen wollen, dass der einzige Weg dagegen anzutreten, Drohnen sind. Und so aus dem einfachen Grund...
Nee, den nukst du dann den Gegner. Das muss die Drohung sein. Nicht, dass der jetzt auch irgendwie unkontrollierbare Drohnenheere loslässt.
Schwierig mit dem Newton.
Nee, das musst du vorher ansagen, nicht wirklich tun. Aber du musst es ansagen. Wenn jemand die Regeln des Krieges verletzt, dann droht ihm einfach das in alle anderen Jugen fertig.
Naja, das sagst du halt einer anderen Nukleararmacht nicht so ohne weiteres.
Eine andere Nukleararmacht wird es von sich aus schon nicht tun, weil sie im Kalten Krieg noch fest daran denkt, wenn sie sich daneben benimmt. Also, ich mein, die haben ja nicht mal im Kalten Krieg sich gegenseitig ihre Botschaften gestürmt und so. Weil es gibt halt so Grenzen, die überquerst du nicht. Oder wie du vorhin meintest, mit ICBMs, das setzt du auch nicht ein, weil du weißt, dass die Gegenseite dann denkt, okay, also wenn wir uns an diese Regel schon nicht mehr halten.
Jetzt denken wir mal kurz daran, dass Drohnen halt genau wie im Cyberwar halt unter einem massiven Attributionsproblem leiden. Nämlich, dass du halt Drohnen, wenn die halt eh alle aus China kommen, weil da sowieso alle Teile hergestellt werden, du halt einfach nicht mehr sagen kannst, wer dich dann da gerade angegriffen hat oder dich da gerade angreift. Naja, also das.
Im Normalfall wären es die Amis gewesen.
Okay, also die Amis sagen halt immer, die Chinesen waren es und alle anderen sagen wahrscheinlich, wären es gerade die Amis gewesen. Aber denken wir mal ein paar Jahre weiter. Gucken wir uns mal an, was sich Boston Dynamics da gerade baut. Also Boston Dynamics ist so eine Bude in Ameland. Die sind halt bekannt für diesen Big-Dock-Roboter, das ist halt so ein Pack-Esel-Roboter.
Das war nur der Anfang, die haben ganz krasse Teile gebaut.
So und das Ding ist halt eigentlich, dafür da den Soldaten Rucksäcke hinterherzuschleppen. Und dann haben sie gesagt, naja, umgucken wir die Technologie verwenden. Dann haben sie halt ein Ding gebaut, was Cheater heißt und was halt irgendwie, also das ist Gap-Hard, glaube ich. Also eine raubkatze. Und wenn man dieses Ding auf diesem laufband da laufen sieht, da wird einem echt ganz anders, weil das Ding läuft mit, keine Ahnung, 26 Meilen die Stunde oder so.
50 kmh.
Ja, 50 kmh.
Gut, das ist jetzt kein Lastenesel, aber könnte es sein.
Nee, das Ding, Cheater ist kein Lastenesel, das ist ein Killer-Roboter.
Ja, aber es könnte auch als Lastenesel benutzt werden. Also das ist nicht so, wenn du einmal eine Technologie hast, die so schnell laufen kann, dann diese ganzen Grenzen, die es bei Menschen gibt.
genau, der kann ja Verbandpäckchen bringen.
genau. Oder der kann dir eine Bombe bringen.
genau. Ja, exakt. Das ist halt genau der Punkt. Oder halt irgendwie 5 Kilo Kokain.
Ja, gut.
Ja, na ja. So, also das ist halt irgendwie, also wir denken mal kurz an Bruce Darling, Heavy Weather. Der hatte ja schon damals irgendwie Delivery Drones, wo du halt irgendwie in einer Wüste sein kannst, eine GPS-Koordinat mit deiner Kreditkarte nochmal angibst und dann kommt deine Drohne angehüpft, die dir eine Delivery bringt.
Eigentlich willst du doch an Fast and Furious denken, hier die ganzen verkackten War-and-Drugs-Operationen, wo sich dann rausstellt, dass das US-Militär die Drogen geschmuggelt hat.
Ja, wie gesagt, die spannende Frage dabei ist ja halt, also wie sieht denn so eine Welt eigentlich aus, in der halt Drohnen obikvetär werden? So, und das fängt halt an bei, du kannst ja halt irgendwie für 300 Euro irgendwie auf Amazon halt so eine Parrot-Drohne klicken, so die Version 2.0 ist sogar ganz geil. Die kannst du halt irgendwie mit deinem Tablet oder deinem Smartphone steuern. Die kann halt nicht viel tragen, da passen halt nur 100 Gramm drunter. Aber das ist halt nur eine Frage der Motortragkraft. Die Steuertechnologie, dass das Ding stabil fliegt, ist halt de facto ein modernes Smartphone. genau, da ist ein DSP drin, da ist ein dicker Arm drin und halt irgendwie ein paar Sensoren. Also das ist halt jetzt nichts Außergewöhnliches. Dementsprechend ist halt auch klar, dass die Frage halt, wer kann alles Drohnen bauen und wie kann man halt verschleiern, wo diese Drohnen herkommen. Die wird halt relativ akut werden. Am Ende wird es halt darauf hinauslaufen, dass man halt irgendeine Art von, naja, du schluckst halt, dann juckt man den anderen halt, aber irgendeine Art von Abschreckungslogik wird es wohl, also die sich halt dann in Verträge gießt, wird es halt wohl geben müssen. Mindestens der Art, dass man sagt halt irgendwie, okay, Drohnen müssen mindestens markiert sein. Also ist halt irgendwie, du brauchst halt irgendwie mindestens keine Ahnung, ein Colorcode für irgendwie zivile und militärische Drohnen und wenn eine Drohne halt irgendwie keinen Transponder sendet und halt keine Identifikation hat, dann wird sie halt von den Killerdrohnen halt runtergeholt.
Das ist überhaupt der nächste Schritt, der noch mal sehr spannend wird, denn das ist eine völlig andere Anforderung, wenn du sagst, du hast jetzt nicht nur eine Drohne, die ein haus angreift, also ein stationäres Ziel, was es nicht kommen sieht, sondern du hast ein anderes bewegliches Ziel in der Luft.
Oder auf dem Boden.
Drohnenkriege, na ja, am Boden ist auch noch eingeschränkt, was der tun kann, um sich in Deckung zu bringen. So ein Cheater? Ja, ich meine, dann baust du halt einen dickeren Sprengsatz ein, der hat halt genug Radius. Aber wenn du eine andere Drohne hast, dann spielt die Latenz plötzlich eine Rolle.
Deswegen musst du sie halt autonom machen.
Und das ist nämlich treibende Kraft hinter diesem Autonomiezeug, dass wenn du anfängst, Drohnenkriege zu haben gegen andere Drohnen, dann geht das einfach nicht mehr von der Latenz her, dass der Mensch das fernsteuert.
Oder auch nur sagt, da ist das Ziel.
Na ja gut, das geht wahrscheinlich schon noch, weil du siehst sie ja, bevor der Reich soweit ist.
Lass uns mal kurz extrapolieren. Also wir nehmen mal wieder hypothetisch eine europäische hauptstadt als Ziel. Und dann hast du da plötzlich 20 von solchen Cheaters durch die Gegend drin, die dann plötzlich 80 Gramm Haar laufen. Das heißt, die sind halt innerhalb von vier Minuten durch dein Regierungsviertel durch. Was tust du da? Da hast du nicht mehr die Zeit als Mensch zu reagieren. Da kannst du nur noch automatisch reagieren.
Technologie war einfach ein Fehler, muss man sagen.
Rückblick betrachten.
Beim Rat hätten wir aufhören sollen.
Na ja, gut, also sagen wir mal, Röhrentechnologie ging doch aber danach, wo das dann problematisch wäre. Na gut.
Haben wir noch Reste von guter laune übrig, die wir zertreten können?
Reste von guter laune, die wir zertreten können.
Ich glaube, wir haben schon die ganzen negativ furchtbaren Sachen.
Ja, na gut, also die Frage ist halt eben, die wir noch mal reinreiben sollten.
Moment, es gibt hier noch ein Faktor-Eat, was du hattest. Das März 2011 gab es so eine Übersicht und da hat die Air Force mehr Piloten für Drohnenkampf ausgebildet als für normale, für alle anderen Waffensysteme. Das heißt, da geht es nicht nur hin, sondern da geht es mit Macht hin. Der Rest will keine Rolle mehr spielen.
Wir reden davon, dass jede Air Force, die irgendwie halbwegs Grip im Kopf hat, die mitmachen will, sogar die Militär, wird keine Signifikantinvestition in bemanter Systeme mehr tätigen. Diese Diskussion, die wir erzählen, in Deutschland haben, dass die Bundeswehr Drohnen haben will, gut kann man verstehen, dass sie bewaffnete Drohnen haben will, da muss man ganz klar sagen, liebe Abgeordnete, lasst euch bitte mal ganz genau erklären, wie sich die Bundeswehr vorstellt, was denn mit der Autonomie ist. Weil ich meine, Autonomie, also solchen Drohnen, muss man auch mal klar sagen, ist im Zweifel ein Software-Upgrade. Oder halt vielleicht nochmal einen schnelleren Prozessor nachstecken. Aber das ist halt nicht irgendwie noch mal ein neues Milliarden-System kaufen.
Nein, nicht nur das, sondern es ist ja auch so, dass wir schon sagen können, dass wir die Software in den zivilen Systemen nicht im Griff haben. Also das finde ich ja das Beunruhigendste daran, wie häufig wir hier irgendwie die Browser und Flash patchen müssen. Und das in Vergleich zu übersichtlicher Software, im Vergleich zu was in so einer Drohne drin ist.
Was hattest du da vorhin irgendwie?
Hör mir auf.
Klicken Sie doch bitte hier und akzeptieren Sie dieses Euro-Unterstand leider nicht im Fenster.
Ja, das hat nicht gereicht, der Updater. So ist das eben heute die ganze, was ja das Vorbild ist für Militär. Der zivile Sektor ist einfach nicht mehr auf Qualität ausgerichtet, sondern es wird geschippt, wenn der Updater funktioniert. Und das ist das niveau, auf dem heute Software entwickelt wird. Und da ist die zivile Seite noch führend. Das will ich gar nicht daran denken, was das Militär macht. Aber wenn wir uns darauf hin...
Ich hab da mal ein bisschen reingeguckt.
Will ich das hören? Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Das ist eines der Stichworte des Echtzeitjabers.
Oh mein Gott. Ausgerechnet.
Und es gibt auch noch Korber. Ja, also... Die Frage, die Frage...
Gut, aber dann mach ich mir eigentlich weniger Drohnen gerade, mach mir gerade weniger Sorgen vor dem Drohnenkrieg, wenn die noch Korber und Java erfahren, sondern kann das nicht so schlimm werden. Soll das die Kommando-Kontrollsysteme... Ich mein, du weißt das, als du diese Statistik gesehen hast, von, wie ist denn dieses, irgendein Malware-Botnet, Black irgendwas, hab ich den Namen schon wieder verdrängt, die haben eine Statistik rausgebracht, dass 95 Prozent von ihren Infektionen über Java gehen. Das ist einfach die eine Lücke, über die sie den allermeisten erfunden. Das weißt du, wenn du mir jetzt erzählst, dass das Militär auf Echtzeit-Java setzt. Vernetzt natürlich, damit die miteinander reden können.
Die machen da noch anderes. Es war so eine Stätte, die mir halt so auffiel. Auf der anderen Seite ist es schon so, dass die daran, gerade für die kritischen Feuerleitprozesse, da haben sie halt schon Zeug, wo sie halt nach EL7 Plus zertifizierte Software und CPF zu rennen.
Hör mir auf mit Zertifizierung.
Na ja, gut, die ist halt immerhin bewiesen.
Ja, wenn wir jemanden hätten, der beweisen kann, dass Software sicher ist, dann würden wir denen die Software schreiben lassen und nicht umbeweisen lassen.
Das ist halt relativ teuer.
Ja, es geht einfach nicht. Ich glaube kein Wort.
Gut, also sie versuchen es halt schon, aber klar ist halt das Risiko, dass ihnen der Zwerg abhanden kommt oder halt nicht mehr funktioniert. Das ist halt schon groß. Interessant ist ja zum Beispiel die Gerüchtelage zu dieser Drohne, die sie im Irak verloren haben. Da haben sie ja so eine RQ-170 Sentinel verloren. Das ist halt so eine Stealth-Drohne. Und die Frage ist halt, wie haben die Iraner diese Drohne eingesammelt? Und da gibt es halt mehrere Theorien. Eine Theorien ist, dass sie halt ein GPS gespoofed haben, relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass das alleine gereicht hat. Dann gibt es die Theorie, dass die Chinesen in das Remote-Control Center sich reingehackt haben und entsprechend manipuliert haben, um dann den Iranern halt irgendwie noch ein bisschen Hardware zu geben, damit sie das Ding halt runterholen können. Dann gibt es noch die, aus meiner Sicht, etwas plausiblere Theorie, dass sie nämlich einfach, nachdem die Amis da halt irgendwie länglich rumgeflogen sind und halt irgendwie sich schon wussten, wann das Ding kommt, sich einfach ein Transportblockzeug davor gesetzt haben und da, ich weiß nicht, trockeneißer da irgendwas rausgekippt haben und ein Triebwerks-Flamm-Out erzeugt haben, um es dann einzusammeln, halte ich für wahrscheinlicher, aber gut, egal wie.
Ein Vogelschwarm?
Klar, es ist jedenfalls die Frage der elektronischen Sicherheit von Drohnen, wird natürlich dramatisch höher. Wie kann man denn sicherstellen, dass gerade insbesondere bewaffnete Drohnen noch einem selber gehorchen und gehören? Und es hat ja Daniel Suarez, ein Kill-Decision fängt ja auch so an, also gerade so ein aktuelles Buch, wo es um Drohnen geht, der fängt halt damit an, dass so eine Reaper-Drohne halt irgendeinen heiligen Schrein zerstört. So und sie hat die erste Theorie, die natürlich erstmal alle haben, wir haben hier die Kontrolle verloren über diese Drohne, sodass irgendjemand, die absichtlich so programmiert hat, wird halt erstmal nicht in Betracht gesungen.
Das ist auch genau dieselbe Scheiße, die wir jetzt schon im zivilen Bereich haben. Die Parallelen drängen sich geradezu aufwendig. Wir haben ja neulich erst die Sendung über Cyberwar gemacht. Und es ist doch genau dasselbe, dass irgendwelche Leute, bei irgendjemandem wird irgendwas Schlimmes auf der Festplatte gefunden und dann behauptet der auch erstmal, oh, da bin ich wohl gehackt worden. Das haben wir jetzt als plausible Ausrede in so gut wie allen Fällen. Oh, da muss ich wohl gehackt worden sein, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht. Und das gekoppelt mit heute, also Version 2.0 davon, dass die Chinesen waren. Weil heute es waren immer die Chinesen, du kannst einfach die Untersuchung einstellen, sobald irgendjemand sagt, das müssen die Chinesen gewesen sein, weil das glaubt sofort jeder und da wird noch nie jemand für gefeuert worden, wenn die Chinesen gehackt haben. genau, also das ist ja auch unsere Bundesregierung hat sich auch eingereicht. Das waren ja auch die Chinesen bei unserer Regierung. Was, also die Chinesen sind es auch in vielen Fällen. Das will ich gar nicht in Abrede stellen, aber das ist einfach so ein Mem geworden heutzutage. Oh, da müssen mich wohl Chinesen gehackt haben. Tja, also ich finde die gesamte Collage, die sich hier ergibt, nur gruselig. Wir haben es hier mit Technologie zu tun, die wir nicht im Griff haben, von der wir nicht mal wissen, wo es hingehen wird, weil wir schon absehen können, dass sie missbraucht werden wird. Und wir sehen es schon als Ausrede benutzt, dass jemand anderes sie missbrauchen wird, dafür, dass wir sie auch missbrauchen müssen. Und wir sehen, dass wir die Software nicht hinkriegen werden, dass wir sie jetzt schon nicht hinkriegen und dass es auch überhaupt keine Perspektive gibt, in der wir sie jemals hinkriegen werden. Und wir sehen, dass es Cyberwar tatsächlich mit Todesfolge gibt, und zwar nicht nur im Sinne von wir drehen den Strom ab und das krankenhaus kann nicht mehr, sondern im Sinne von die Drohne schießt daneben und er legt den Präsidenten. Ich meine, das sind doch alles Aussichten, die man nicht haben will.
Also es gibt halt natürlich eine Gegenbewegung, also die wichtigste ist halt das Komitee und Robert Arms-Control, die entstanden ist aus der Kampagne gegen Landminen. Aber ich vermute mal, dass...
Na da ist doch auch ein Totgeburt. Die Landminen haben alle Länder geächtet, bis auf die USA. Na wuppa.
So der Punkt ist halt, ich vermute mal, dass sich die Lage halt wirklich erst ändern wird, wo eben genau diese Länder, die momentan halt der Technologieführerschaft haben, deswegen halt auf gar keinen Fall irgendeine Art von Restriktionen oder Abkommen wollen, nämlich insbesondere die Amis.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist nicht so völlig falsch. Das Abkommen wird genau wie bei Atomwaffen als strategischer Schach zu gehen. Wenn du glaubst, deine Technologie ist so weit, dass du die anderen ohnen kannst, dann verbietest du Entwicklung, weitere Forschung in dem Bereich.
genau.
So, dafür alle anderen, damit die nicht zu dir aufließen können.
Der Punkt ist halt, dass das halt völlig illusorisch ist, weil du brauchst halt keine speziellen Materialien dafür. Und genau wie wir halt irgendwie bei Cluster Bomben und Landminen gesehen haben, interessiert es am Ende halt dann doch niemanden so. Also dann gibt es halt irgendwie mal einen kritischen Artikel im Guardian und das war dann halt so.
Na ja, das ist wie mit den, das ist wie mit, von den Chinesen gehackt werden, ist halt, wenn du sagst, die Mine kam von den Amis, dann sagst du nur, ja dann können wir nichts machen.
Muss wohl irgendwo verloren gegangen sein.
Wobei, auch bei Atomtechnologie kommt gelegentlich vor, dass irgendein Boy Scout in seiner Garage eine Fusion zwischen Atomscout, aber bei Drohnen ist die Schwelle halt deutlich weniger.
Eines der Dinge, die wir vermutlich da sehen würden, sind halt Versuche für Technologiekontrolle durchzusetzen. Also, dass man halt keine unmarkierten, autonomen Systeme bauen darf.
Aber das glaubst du doch nicht wirklich, oder?
Ich würde das mal nicht ausschließen, weil die Historie zeigt ja, dass es schon in der Regel gelungen ist, wirklich gefährlich Technologie schon zu reglementieren. Zumindest in einer Waffe zum Beispiel.
Ja, schon reglementiert, ja.
Na, in Europa zumindest schon.
So gut wie nie jemand erschossen in Europa. Also nur selten gelegentlich.
Na ja, wenn ich mir Deutschland so angucke, ist es schon durchaus im Vergleich zu den USA.
Ja, ist gering, aber weißt du, schon eine wilde Drohne reicht, dass du nachts nicht gut schlafen kannst.
genau, und deswegen denke ich mal, dass es halt irgendwie dazu führen wird, dass es halt Policing geben wird. Also, dass halt klar ist, Drohnen, die halt unmarkiert rumfliegen, die fliegen halt nicht lange. Oder unmarkiert rumlaufen.
Aber das heißt doch, dass wir eine Infrastruktur brauchen, um autonomen Drohnen abzuschießen. Das ist doch genau dasselbe.
Na ja, andere Drohnen.
Ja eben, aber das ist doch dasselbe Problem. Dann kann ich doch sagen, wir lösen das Waffenproblem, in dem wir Waffen verteilen. Das ist der Schweizer Ansatz, ja super.
Na ja, nee, wir lösen es. Also in Deutschland ist ja der Ansatz zu sagen, wir lösen das Waffenproblem, in dem wir nur die Polizei bewaffnen.
Ja, aber ich mein, wir sehen ja, was das bringt.
Na ja, doch relativ viel.
In der Bevölkerung gibt es wenig Waffen bei den normalen Leuten, aber die Kriminellen haben ja doch keine Sorgen, kein Problem damit, sich Waffen zu verschaffen.
Gibt es in Deutschland halt irgendwie weniger Waffentote als die anderen. Ja, sehr viel weniger. Das stimmt schon. Nur so dieses Beispiel, dass die deutsche Polizei hat irgendwie 2011 86 Schüsse abgegeben, die New Yorker Polizei hat 89 Schüsse abgegeben, um einen Wahnsinnigen und irgendwie nur einen haufen Beistern das zu erschießen.
Ein Meth-Freak. Nein, aber ich meine, das Argument möchte ich noch mal kohärent zusammenfassen. Wir sagen jetzt, um uns gegen die möglicherweise unprogrammierten, autonomen Drohnen von irgendwelchen... Oder absichtlich bösen Drohnen zu schützen, wollen wir selber autonome Drohnen verteilen, die die dann abfangen, wenn sie nicht markiert sind. Das ist doch...
Nee, darauf wird sich ein auslauf vermuten.
Ja, aber das ist doch totaler Bullshit. Also wir sind uns doch einig, oder?
Das ist halt nur eine reine Extrapolation.
Also ich halte es auch für plausibel, dass es dahingehend wird. Das ist so eine typische Sache, wo ich mir vorstellen kann, dass die CDU dafür ist.
Ja, oder die CSU. Und die FDP wird fordern, dass es einen freien Markt dafür gibt.
genau. Gut, die Marktwirtschaft darf nicht aufgehalten werden.
Na gut.
Tja, wir haben ja noch, ich habe hier noch so ein bisschen Zukunftsvisionen drin.
Ja genau, da fehlen noch ein paar Zukunftsvisionen.
Eine von denen, die man häufig in der Presse sieht und in Sci-Fi-Filmen ist, dass man Insektengroße Drohnen hat. Das ist eine Sache, an der auch schon gearbeitet wird. Die können dann halt nicht irgendwie angreifen. Das sind keine Killerdrohnen. Aber es ist natürlich denkbar, wenn man sich vorstellt, dass man so eine Mücke hat und die sticht dich dann und injiziert ein bisschen Gift oder Polonium. Das ist durchaus denkbar, eine Killerdrohne in der Größenordnung zu bauen. Und die nächste Stufe nennt sich Smart Dust. Das könnt ihr ja mal googeln. Also schlauer staub. Ganz gruselige Visionen, die die Sci-Fi-Leute jetzt überlegt haben. Und an der Stelle möchte ich eine Sache mal ansagen. Wenn ihr überlegt, Sci-Fi-Lektöre zu schreiben, seid euch der Verantwortung bewusst. Weil das wird mit Sicherheit irgendwann von den nächsten Generationen als Militäroptionen gebaut werden. Mir ist vorhin erst wieder so ein Ding aufgefallen. Bei Star Wars gibt es irgendwie so ein völlig sinnloses Detail am Rande. Da gibt es irgendwie so einen Planeten, da fliegen dann so Tiere rum, die so in so einer Größe Ordnung ein Bus oder ein Elefant sind und die sehen aus wie so ein längliches, irgendwie wie so ein Rochen, ja? Also breite Flügel und in der Mitte so ein torpedoförmiges Teil. Da dachte ich so, was für ein Blödsinn, wer denkt sich denn so einen Scheiß aus? Und dann guckst du dir an, wie heute die Drohnen aussehen, die in so einer Höhe rumfliegen und die sind vielleicht nicht so groß, aber die Form stimmt und die flappen jetzt nämlich mit den Flügeln rum, aber so die Torpedo-Form stimmt schon mal, ja.
Und Luftschifftrohnen, wenn ihr gebaut.
Die Leute werden sich an euren Visionen orientieren. Das heißt, wenn ihr Sci-Fi Lektüre schreiben wollt, so ein Zwickschen, dann schreibt sie bitte positiv.
Beziehungsweise wenn ihr Sci-Fi Lektüre nachprogrammiert, dann sucht euch irgendwie positive aus.
Das werden immer irgendwelche Vollidioten machen, deswegen bitte keine Dystopien mehr schreiben, da haben wir genug von. Die werden alle wahr.
Na gut, damit sind wir so am Ende. Wir entschuldigen uns dafür, dass wir euch eine leicht depressive Stimmung zurückgelassen haben, es wird ja ohnehin Winter. Dann, falls ihr noch Lust habt, da gibt es den Flatterbutton an der Seite und...
genau, dann haben zumindest wir wieder gute laune.
Da haben wir wieder ein bisschen bessere laune, genau. Wo wir euch für uns immer diese depressiven Themen und Sendungen antun. Und dann bedanken wir uns fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.